- They would do this thing at my pool,
where they would have like
how to learn how to kayak in the pool.
- Like in the pool?
- Yeah, they would they would
put six kayaks in the pool
and just let people kayak around it.
And I don't know how this happened,
but after the kayakers left,
there was a shit in the pool?
Now, they're in kayaks.
How do they get in the pool?
Kids are fucking weird, man.
- Kids are weird.
(gentle upbeat music)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of "Trash Taste."
I am your host for today, Garnt, Grant,
whatever the fuck you wanna call me,
and with me, as usual, is the boys
- The boys.
- You know it's really selfish
of you to have that name,
because it's really inconvenient for me
when I'm texting about you.
- Oh, really?
It keeps auto correcting.
- It want's to keep correcting it.
You know how inconvenience
that is to me, Garnt?
- Do you know how inconvenient it is
when it auto-corrects my own name
when I'm referring to myself? (laughs)
- It's even more inconvenient,
'cause when you look up Garnt
on like Wikipedia it goes
to my fucking Wikipedia?
- Yeah, what the fuck.
Like fucking tin foil hat.
- When you look up, I think it's like,
I saw it on the subreddit,
it's like, when you look up Gigguk,
it's like the Anime Man.
(laughing)
- What is Gigguk's real name?
Joey Bazinga.
Bazinga, sorry.
(laughing)
- Bazinga.
- I fucking said it.
- You've known each other for how long?
Fucking hell.
- So how are you doing boys?
It's been a while.
You guys don't know this,
but it's been like a three-week break
since we last recorded through
the magic of scheduling.
You wouldn't have had a break at all,
but yeah, it's been three weeks,
since we last had a recording.
- Yeah, I mean...
- We had a three week break, right?
Because, well, you went
on journey across Japan.
- I went on journey,
across Japan.
- A broad and a man.
- [Garnt] A broad and a man.
- I also hung out with
Chris before that in Kyoto.
So it was like kind of
like an awkward timing
where it was like three weeks
where we couldn't record.
- Yeah, but I don't know, it's
been a nice refresh, I'd say.
- Yeah.
- Came back and...
- Sick of fucking seeing
you guys. (laughing)
- Yeah, God.
(laughing)
Every week, Jesus man.
- I mean it's 'cause I think normally,
especially when we did
three episodes in one week,
'cause that's what we
did to allow us to do it.
On the last episode I was like fine,
what are we we're talking about?
- There's only so much I
can chat shit, you know,
if we're chatting shit every day,
for like three times a week or whatever.
- And it's not like we're all going out
and doing like interesting
things every day, right?
It's like five days out of a week,
we're just in our room like
just working on videos.
- Yeah, I mean we talked
about this earlier,
but like how do like streamers
who stream every day,
and just like, what do they talk about?
'Cause sometimes when we have
more than one recording a
week, sometimes I'm like,
I don't know what the fuck
to talk about sometimes.
Like what's going on new with you guys.
- I was like, the barrel is very shallow.
(laughing)
It's like the bottom is just there.
- What's going on new?
Oh, playing games?
Oh, you're playing Apex.
Oh, just like last week?
Oh, cool.
- And what am I supposed to do
if like the police don't
stop me once a week, right?
Like what am I supposed to talk about?
- I need to commit a
crime to make a story.
- I'm like running out of stories, man.
What am I supposed to do?
It's like if you're streamer,
you've got to be talking
about the other streams,
that happened (indistinct).
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- Just gotta like watch YouTube
videos, that's about it.
- Some had this, really
funny name last stream
called, Peepee Poopoo.
That was a really fun moment.
- Let me drag that out for 15 minutes.
I mean, it's like, I don't know.
I don't know how much
I'm allowed to talk about
journeying across Japan,
because I think at this point
it's probably-
- It's free promo Chris.
- Yeah, it's probably, not even out yet,
but I think the trailer
will be out by then.
So if you wanna check that out, I guess.
- Here's a teaser, Joey won't
say everything that happened,
I'm sure.
- Just go,
and watch the videos.
- Yeah just go watch the videos, whatever.
- I mean yeah,
I literally came back yesterday
as of us recording this.
So yeah-
- How was it?
Was it-
- Oh it was fucking insane.
- Hype it up!
- Hype it up for Chris.
- I'll hype it up.
All right, I'll hype it up for Chris.
Journey across Japan two,
I should probably explain
what Journey Across Japan is.
So if you don't know,
Journey Across Japan is a
series that Chris Broad,
who's been on the show a couple of times-
- Let me guess, you go across Japan?
- We go across Japan-
- I was gonna say, it
kind of speaks for itself.
- It's a show we do
together on Chris' channel,
where we go across
Japan, do like challenges
and like go visit cool places in Japan
And Journey Across Japan Three,
is like the third one we just finished,
where we went through Kyushu,
which is like the most
Southern island in Japan.
Awesome because I'd never
been to Kyushu, like at all.
And just this past week,
I went through all the
prefectures of Kyushu in one go.
So it was fucking great.
- Speed running tourism.
- Yeah we were speed
running Kyushu, literally.
- I like how Chris took you
around all the amazing places,
and he took me to like
the shittiest place.
(laughs)
- Did he?
- Didn't you go to like a
gin factory or something?
- No 'cause, we did go to a gin factory,
- Was that like the highlight?
- That was the highlight, yeah.
Just got to drink really
nice gin, that was like free,
which is like-
- Oh that's cool.
- Yeah, then you can just be
like, make me this cocktail,
and they made it, which is great.
Which is like just a power
trip that I needed in my life.
- But you've already been to Kyoto, right?
- Yeah, I've been once before.
But he found this Welsh town,
like Welsh British town,
like an hour-
- In Kyoto?
- In like an hour in the
mountains in Kyoto, drive.
- Wow.
And it was,
yeah, it was pretty shit.
(laughs)
It was good, but it was just kinda like
really underwhelming.
- Was it just like home or?
- Weirdly, weirdly yeah.
- Did you feel like
culturally appropriated in it? (laughs)
- I don't know.
Is this how people feel
when they see white
people wearing kimonos?
(laughing)
I'm like this kind of cool,
but like what's going on?
Like why?
- I also wanted you
to be like, "Oh God, this is so shit.
Just reminds me of home."
(laughing)
- I mean, yeah basically.
I feel bad dogging on it.
It was just kind of like,
it was really bizarre and like
underwhelming, I don't know.
But also the fish and chips
is $22, which is criminal.
- I mean, I'm sure like,
I don't know how it feels
like for say like, you know,
someone who lived in China
going to like China town,
or something like that?
- Well I mean, it's kind of
different, though, isn't it?
- Is it?
- There's always like markets
and restaurants, right?
- Yeah, that's true.
- I feel like Chinatown is
never like, this actually China.
- Okay, describe to me
this Welsh town then?
- So there was-
- Yeah, what about it made it Welsh?
- All the buildings looked
like they were just pulled out
of like a small town in Wales.
It was really weird.
And it was just really old style,
like the places where you'd
find in like West Wales,
and it was just really strange,
'cause it's like, I didn't particularly-
- [Joey] Was like everything
written in Welsh or?
- [Connor] Well, one
of the pubs was called,
Pond Oak and pond means bridge in Welsh.
- [Joey] Oh, okay
At least they were
accurate about it, right?
- [Connor] That was pretty cool.
- Are people fucking
sheep around the corner?
(laughs)
- No I was there,
(laughing)
- It's a deer, bring your own sheep.
- It was, okay.
I'm just pretty sure I'm really
sarcastic about everything.
And it was just like,
I feel like this is the one
time where I can be like,
time to actually become
sarcastic about something,
and no one can correct to me
'cause I'm fucking British.
- This is my culture now.
Welcome to my culture.
(laughs)
- It probably wasn't as offensive,
as the first time I went to
a Outback Steakhouse, right?
And I was just like, is this
what Australia is to everyone?
Fucking boomerangs on the wall everywhere?
Yeah, just like in an Australian home.
- I don't really know.
I mean, I'm pretty, I kinda
bash on every culture,
but I by far bash on my own culture
more than anything.
- Well, that's good,
because if it was anything else,
if it was anything else,
it'd be really bad to say right now.
- Americans be like, "Oh really?"
(laughing)
- I'm pretty harsh-
- A fucking vein
popping out their head.
- I'm pretty harsh on Americans,
I feel like I'm more harsh,
on the UK-
- I feel like,
that's just part of
British culture, right?
Because you rag on everyone equally,
but you especially rag
on your own culture.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- But like for some reason
when someone else rags on
your culture, you're like,
no only I get to complain
about my culture,
thank you very much.
- It's the one-time
everyone becomes patriotic.
- I feel like being British
you can't really complain anymore.
Everyone fucking mocks British people now.
So you kinda just get used to it.
I'm just like, yes, honey.
Oh, you made another British
meme, bottle of water?
All right, yes, honey.
- I feel like self-deprecation
is just part of British
culture, and British mentality.
- It's such an amazing fall though, right?
Like, especially on YouTube.
'Cause like remember like-
- The rise and fall of British culture.
- No, because remember in like 2015,
everyone was fucking obsessed
with British culture,
and now everyone's like,
"Oh, innit is the English form of desu."
- I think it's just 'cause,
the internet has just realized,
what British people actually sound like.
(laughing)
- To be fair, I always wondered
that When I was growing up.
I'm like no one sounds
like this around me.
- Everyone in the UK doesn't
sound like Harry Styles?
What?
- And I'm just like, what?
'Cause I remember growing up, I was like,
when I the world gonna realize
that people don't sound like
they do in Harry Potter,
or every other like British film,
or like "Doctor Who" or whatever, right?
- I'm just waiting for the day
that everyone realizes that
not everyone in Australia that
looks like Chris Hemsworth.
- Debatable.
I know like two people
and they look, you know,
you're one of them, you look close enough.
- To Chris Hemsworth?
- Yeah.
- You get ripped, you'll
look like Chris Hemsworth.
- No, if I get ripped I'll
look like Jason Mamoa.
(laughing)
- [Garnt] Oh, yeah. (laughs)
- What are you waiting for, Joey?
Tell me what else did you
get up to then in Fukuoka,
that you can tease for us.
- Okay, I can tease, well, I mean,
Journey Across Japan, so
there's always a theme.
So like the first
Journey Across Japan was-
- Was cycling.
- Yeah, was Chris cycling,
and I was just on one part of it.
But then the second Journey Across Japan,
I was there fully for it.
And it was called "Escape to Fuji."
So the theme of it was
we went around Mount Fuji
and like all the cool places
we can go to Mount Fuji,
because Chris had never seen
a nice view of Mount Fuji,
in his life.
So he's never taken one of
those like touristy photos.
And he kept like,
apparently his audience
kept sending him pictures
of amazing views.
It's like, "Hey look, Chris,
I was here for two days,
and I got an amazing view of Mount Fuji"
Fuck you.
- You can check it out now, by the way.
- Yeah, you can check it
out now, it's all there.
So the third Journey
Across Japan is called,
"The Lost Islands,"
because the Kyushu area
has all these like tiny-
- Like Jurassic park, here man.
- Yeah, right?
(Garnt laugh)
- Even though like the
fucking promotional artwork,
looks like a fucking shitty movie poster.
It's like a (indistinct),
I said shitty, it looks amazing.
But like, yeah so the Kyushu area,
it's almost like an
archipelago of just these,
like insane amount of tiny-
- Wait, what was that word,
sorry?
- Archipelago.
- What the fuck?
Someone needs to whip out a dictionary,
what is that?
- An archipelago it's like-
- Is like a group of islands, right?
- Is like a group of islands.
- I've never heard of this.
I'm not even gonna pretend to be smart.
I did not know that word, man.
- An archipelago is
basically like a group,
of lots of small islands-
- When did you learn
that word Joey?
Did you learn it before the trip? (laughs)
- No, I learnt it...
(laughing)
- That is not a common word.
- I learnt it in school.
- It's in like films.
- Did you guys know that word?
You guys knew that word?
Did you know that word Meilyne?
- An archipelago?
- Meilyne didn't know
that word either.
(laughs)
- Really, you're looking for Meilyne's
to be on your side here.
- Oh, fuck of.
- Well, it's something.
- So like the Philippines for
example is an archipelago,
because it's just a bunch of tiny,
tiny, tiny islands, right?
- Stop flexing.
So basically in layman's-
- It's fucking cross-pollination
all over again, man.
- In layman's terms,
there's a lots of tiny, tiny islands,
along the coast of Kyushu.
So we were like, oh, that's perfect.
We'll call it the lost islands,
because we'll try and
go to as many of these,
like small islands.
And I think we ended up going
to like three or four of them.
I mean, obviously, we
couldn't go to all of them,
'cause there's literally
thousands of them out there.
But some of these islands
were fucking insane looking.
Like completely off the-
- Yeah, you showed me
some pictures.
- Yeah, I showed pictures.
- It's gonna be fun, you
guys need to watch it.
- But yeah, it was just incredible.
Like we literally did speed run Kyushu.
'Cause like that week felt like a month.
It was fucking insane.
- It sounds like you did a fuck ton,
from how you were describing it to me.
- Honestly the challenges that we like,
usually prepare with on
Journey Across Japan,
this time around was like
kind of a back-burner,
just because there's so
much shit we were doing.
We were like, oh yeah,
I forgot we had to do
a challenge for this video, fuck.
But yeah, hopefully the
trailer will be out,
by the time this episode goes out?
- If Chris isn't lazy.
- If not, sorry, Chris,
I probably just sent a bunch
of where's the trailer people,
over to your channel.
- He had it coming.
- What I wanna know is
that how many more places
can he do Journey Across Japan?
How many more themes can he do?
Because like one thing I
will say about Japan is that,
one of the things that
impresses me the most,
is just how fucking varied Japan is
in terms of like how many
places there are to travel,
and to explore.
And I'm just like, 'cause
I'm used to the UK, right?
And I feel like if you've explored,
a decent amount of the UK,
then you've kind of, to me at least,
you've kind of seen it all.
- There's like one town.
- Yeah, yeah.
If you go to one town, you go to one city,
and it's kind of all the same.
I mean, London to me,
London kind of exists in its own bubble.
London's like unique, but like
anywhere outside of London,
I mean fucking-
- Shit.
(laughs)
It's the same innit?
- Australia's the same thing, right?
I think geographically, it's
just as large as like the US,
maybe close to it.
- It's just sand, so.
- It's like 80% of it is a fucking desert.
That's why like I barely
gone exploring in Australia,
because I'm just like,
I just don't know what there is out there.
But then again, if Chris
hadn't like gone and done
extensive research on places in Kyushu,
I probably would have had no fucking idea
what to do right?
- I don't know how Chris
finds these fucking places?
- No, I don't know either.
- He comes to me,
with this town in the Mountains of Kyoto.
- Yeah, right?
- How do you find this stuff?
- He literally just spends months
just researching interesting places.
I remember on Journey Across Japan Two,
there was this like in the
middle of the mountains,
in Gifu prefecture or Toyama,
I think it was Toyama prefecture,
which usually people don't go for tourism.
He found this like in the
middle of the fucking mountains,
there was this like field of
like 1,000 statues of people,
that had just been built.
And you know how he found it?
He literally went on to
like Google satellite,
and just like scanned
through the mountains,
- Oh my God.
- What the fuck!
- Until he stopped and was
like, what is this gray blob?
And like enhanced.
- Enhanced.
- And then saw that
there were these statues.
'Cause if you look it up,
before that video went up,
there was no articles about it.
Not even Japanese media talks about it.
- Dude, this is like some next level.
This is like some NASA shit, man.
- Yeah and I was like,
I want your dedication to research.
- People do strange things
with their land in Japan.
In the UK, you just kinda ave a field,
and maybe you put a fence on it
kinda like let's call
it a day but in Japan-
- There's only so much things you can do.
- Yeah, in Japan they
seem to go crazy with it.
They're like, what if we just made a field
that's just trampoline outside.
And they're like all right do it.
- If you look it up, there's
probably someone out there
that has it, all right.
- Trampoline wardo.
- That's what's so awesome about Japan,
is that you can just be driving
in the middle of nowhere
and then you just see like
this weird fucking place
that you don't know what mad
man came up with this idea.
Just put like a field of statues
or something like that right?
- And it's not even like
built for tourism either,
because it's not even known, right?
It's like if you're
lucky enough to find it,
then there you go, there it is, enjoy it.
- I'm hoping the next Journey Across Japan
is just five star hotels
and Chris is like, come
on Connor, let's go.
Let's go and review five-star hotels.
(laughing)
I'm down for that.
- Journey Across Michelin
Restaurants in Japan.
(laughing)
- Not only is it a tax deductible,
it's also fantastic.
It's fun, I wanna do this.
- Yeah, but please look
forward to that whenever that,
I think he said it's coming
out end of May, maybe?
So, hopefully soon.
- So like how many more places in Japan,
do you want to visit personally?
- So I have this app actually on my phone,
where you can keep track of,
it's what I use to keep track
of all the prefectures I've been to.
- Google?
- It's called Google maps.
- Well there's that as well.
- It stalks you, right?
It knows exactly where you are?
- So like have we told the
story about the cycling, yet?
- Yeah okay, I mean so, I
know because I like this,
that Google tells me exactly
where I was for how long?
I like looking back where I was and like,
'cause when people ask me,
oh, where are you this day?
I'm like, oh, let me check, and I'm like,
oh, I know I've been-
- When the police ask me
where were you this day?
- When the Japanese police officers,
are asking for my alibi,
I've got one ready.
But like it tells you exactly
where you were, for how long.
And when we did the cycling special,
we all had our phone tracking on,
it wasn't shown in the video,
but we actually saw where we
all were throughout the video.
And when the video was done,
I asked them, I was like,
hey guys, can you export your map data,
so that we can send it to our editor,
so that he can know
where we, where we were.
- So that's how you see
all the cool map graphics
that Meilyne made.
- It's not 100% accurate,
but it's pretty close.
- It's pretty close, yeah.
- It's pretty close.
- So where we are generally
on that map is actually,
where we were.
- So we turn on
location services, which I didn't know,
that you could track each other
in like in real time.
- In real time, yeah.
So it wasn't a part of like the big,
we didn't make it a big
part of the special,
but we could actually see where we were,
as we were cycling down.
I could see that Joey was
fucking kicking my ass,
and Connor turned off
his location sharing,
when he was taking the ferry.
So he just like popped out of existence
and then popped in existence again.
- I literally thought he
was like lost out to sea.
- Yeah, I just said
it was broken-
- I was like, he's dead.
He's dead, he's just straight up dead.
- Yeah.
- So there was no signal.
- Exactly.
- When I asked these guys to share it,
they were like, wait.
Garnt was like, "Wait, what?
They keep all this information on you?"
I'm like, yeah, it's awesome right?
- It's terrifying.
- Yeah so I didn't realize that
by turning on location services,
I could go through my
entire history day by day.
And if you've turned on location services,
you can probably do that right now.
If you go to Google maps,
and you can go through the
history of your location services
and it will tell you the
exact location you've been,
hour by hour, every single day,
for like the past 10 years of your life.
- Yeah, that's really good.
- It's scary.
- That's terrifying.
- Google's literally
stalking you at all times.
- Do you know what's sad,
is like when I used to live in London,
'cause I barely ever left my house,
It would be like, what do I do this day?
It's like a dot on the map
of me not leaving my house.
I'd be like, oh, what did I do this day?
Oh okay, maybe the next.
Okay, well, maybe the next, oh okay.
Four days in a row I
didn't leave the house.
All right, cool.
And then I would just be America.
(laughing)
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
I didn't know, this is like
some fucking FBI shit, man.
- I don't know, 'cause
sometimes I go to a place
and I'm like, oh fuck where was that?
And I can just go on Google
and find out where I was.
- I mean it's cool like
to look back on it, right?
- No, it is cool.
- If you're the only one
looking at it.
- Who wants to look?
- It's like two sides, right?
'Cause it's cool to know that you could go
through your entire life history,
but it's also kind of like, I guess scary,
not scary, but like disturbing
that your entire life
can be compressed down into a file,
and just like analyzed, right?
- That's pretty cool.
- And exported, right?
- And exported, I don't know.
That's just like this the future
that "Black Mirror" warned us about,
- That is some (indistinct).
- I for one, welcome our
"Black Mirror" overlords.
(laughs)
I welcome technology.
I don't know, yeah, I don't know.
I like it. It's fun.
- Yeah.
It's interactive.
- Interactive.
- What you mean interactive?
- It's not stalking, it's interactive.
(laughs)
- No, I can see the cool side of it.
It's just a bit like-
- Wait, why did this
come up again? (chuckles)
- Oh, because you were
asking how many prefectures-
- Oh yeah, so is there any place
that you would love to visit?
- I have an app, that shows me
all the prefectures I've been to,
and I can kind of give
points as well being like,
so it's like, I visited
there, I walked there,
I stayed there overnight,
I lived there, et cetera,
and it like adds on the points.
- I lived here, I did it,
I ate it.
- I did it.
So I know exactly now which prefectures
I haven't been to yet.
And I think, I mean, I can bring it up,
but I think maybe I've done,
I wanna say like 3 1/5 maybe
3 1/4 of all the prefectures,
but yeah, these are the ones I've done.
- Red ones you've been to?
- Holy shit.
- So the red ones
I've stayed overnight.
I'll send this image to you, Meilyne.
But the red ones I've stayed overnight.
The green ones I've
like just stopped over.
The yellow ones I've passed through.
The blue ones I've like walked around.
And the white ones I haven't visited yet.
- Oh, okay.
- There's a decent amount
that I still haven't gone to,
but this is good, right?
Because now I can use that
app basically to be like,
all right, well, you know,
I wanna take the weekend off somewhere.
I can plan my next vacation and be like,
well, I've never been to this prefecture,
so let's go check that out, kind of thing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I wish I wasn't so fucking stupid, man.
- What do you mean?
- I just don't like...
I like don't really care where
I am, unless there's like,
I don't know, something fun to do there.
I'm like, oh-
- Oh yeah, of course.
Yeah.
I wouldn't go to a fucking prefecture,
if I didn't have anything
to do there, right?
- I'm not the type of guy who's just like,
okay, I haven't been to this map here,
I haven't been to this part of the map.
I need to know that there's
something cool to do there.
- See, this is my JRPG,
like 100% completion-ist side, coming out.
'Cause I'm like I gotta
finish all 47 prefectures,
just to complete it.
- For me it's like a catch-22,
'cause I wanna go to new places,
I wanna find new cool places,
but I also don't have the
energy that Chris does
to just fucking scout out places
that look cool.
- Yeah.
Not only scour, but like schedule it
day by day meticulously.
- Yeah, yeah. Right?
- That's why I like going
with someone who plans stuff.
I'm like, you plan it.
I'll come along.
I'll crack a few jokes, here and there.
- That's why I love Journey
Across Japan, right?
It's a fucking vacation for me, right?
It's like, so I have to be on camera
and talk for a few hours a day?
Cool.
- That is definitely
the benefit of hanging out with Chris.
It's like he just takes
care of everything.
He's like, I know where we're going,
I know a place, let's do it.
- He's the definition of I know a place.
(laughing)
- One time I did that for Chris,
I was like, let me take
you to a place, right?
We're in Kyoto, right?
And I was like, no, no, I
know a great coffee place.
Literally outside where we were staying,
there is a Blue Bottle Coffee, right?
It's like the least Kyoto thing ever.
(laughing)
Look at like an American chain,
I'm like, no, no it's good, it's good,
it's good.
- It's good, it's good.
- To be fair, it's pretty fucking good.
- It is the best coffee-
- I know a place.
It's called Starbucks.
- Japanese coffee-
Yeah.
(laughing)
- Starbucksu.
- I can do good coffee there.
- Do we have a clip named Japan's coffee
is bottom tier, because-
- Probably not.
- Well, we do now.
- Yeah, we do now.
- Japan's coffee is the fucking worst.
It's fucking awful.
- It's awful.
- Japan truly is a tea society.
- Tea society. (laughing)
- We live in a tea society.
- It's awful, man.
It's like dirt.
- Yeah, I didn't know
that I cared about coffee,
until I moved to Japan.
And I've realized that
the coffee here was shit.
'Cause I thought living in England,
I'm just like, whatever I would fucking...
I thought like my coffee tolerance was,
I'll fucking take instant
coffee if I need to.
- But like when I moved to Japan,
I've realized what shit
coffee tastes like.
- But then I got a job.
(laughing)
And now I know.
No, because remember the fucking like,
just the brainwashing that happens,
the first time you come
to Japan, you're like,
I can buy a hot coffee
at a vending machine?
Oh my God, I'm gonna buy this
every fucking day.
- Yeah. Oh, my God.
- And then you realize
it's just all sugar.
- And then you realize it's all crap.
And your like, oh Starbucks has never been
so fucking attractive to me.
- So yeah, so yeah, as you know.
As you know Japan has like a
fuck ton of vending machines,
like everywhere.
And I remember whenever I used
to go on holiday in Japan,
I'd always get the coffee,
vending machine coffee
every single day without fail,
and I'm just like, I will never
get bored of this, at all.
This is fucking amazing.
I don't need to go to a fucking Starbucks,
or a coffee shop to get my coffee.
I can just go to a vending machine.
And then I moved here,
and then I don't know what
it is about moving here,
like something switched
in my brain, right?
And then I just instantly
recognized it as like,
oh this tastes like crap.
This is processed instant coffee shit.
And I don't know why,
I don't know what switched my brain.
Like why is it that when
I was here as a tourist,
vending machine coffee and
vending machine drinks,
were just like fucking five-star?
- 'Cause we don't have it in the UK,
so you're like, you do like amazed by it-
- It's just like a new,
weird thing, right?
Like Connor, I remember, was talking about
how every time he came here to visit,
you would fucking eat FamilyMart
or Nigiri every day, right?
And then you realized,
oh, this is not that
great actually. (laughs)
- I've actually gone back on it now.
- Oh really?
You say that like a drunk.
- I've come like full circle.
- I've relapsed. (laughs)
- I was very diehard sandwiches
for like a year and a half.
And now I'm like, man,
I just crave rice now.
What the fuck's going on?
- I mean the onigiris
are fucking great dude.
- Yeah, they are.
- Onigiris are great.
I've never been off them.
- Yeah.
- (laughs) Never been off.
- I realize I just sound
like a druggie right there.
(laughing)
- Depending on-
- Onigiri would sober you Garnt?
- How many onigiris is too much?
- Going back to the coffee, right?
For me, coffee is as much
of like a smell thing,
as it is a drink thing.
The reason why I like
going into a coffee shop,
is 'cause I need that wall
of coffee smell to hit me.
That's what makes me feel like
I'm ready to fucking drink caffeine.
- I'd say coffee is a
fucking morning thing for me,
right now because-
- Not a morning thing,
a fucking morning thing.
- It is a fucking morning.
- Fucking morning.
- 'Cause like honestly is
your morning really started,
if you don't have a coffee?
'Cause to me, if I don't have a coffee,
that's like my indicator
that my morning has begun.
I can begin the day.
If I don't have the coffee,
then I'm just like in
permanent, like 50% brain mode.
- No coffee I sleep, coffee I wake.
- Exactly!
That's literally how I am.
I don't know if it's a placebo thing.
- No, I'm totally the same.
I remember there was one
week where I was like,
I might be a little too
dependent on coffee.
Let me back it up a bit,
because I was having like, two,
three cups of coffee a day.
- Right.
- Well I have like
four or five.
- Yeah, right?
And I'm like, that's probably
not that good for me.
My heart's probably about to explode.
So let me like just go a week,
with no coffee and see how I do.
Dude, day two, I was like.
(Garnt laughing)
I was getting just insane
migraines in my head.
I was like, oh, I'm really
fucking dependent on this shit
to start the day.
- I just get sluggish if I stop.
I don't really get too bad.
- You don't get like coffee headaches?
- No, I've never gotten that.
I've had friends who got it.
- How it feels for me is
that you know that scene
in the film where it's like
they got the gray scale filter on it,
that's how I see the world
before I have my coffee, man.
And then like I have the coffee,
and then they instantly
turn up the saturation.
That is how my mornings work.
- I go from gray-scale to sepia.
- You are the fucking meme of,
don't talk to me until I've had my coffee.
Like you're literally that guy.
- No, 'cause I remember
when I first moved to Japan,
and my mornings were
just like so depressing.
'Cause I didn't have that
first good, hot coffee
to look forward to, right?
Because even if I'd go to my
FamilyMart to get a coffee,
it was like really watered down coffee.
It wasn't, I don't know.
I've noticed the more I like grow up,
it's the little things in life
that you need to look forward to.
I don't know.
- It's the little things.
- It is the little things.
Like my mornings are 20% less happy
if I don't have a coffee
to look forward to.
- Yeah, I just feel like
my day is depressing.
That's kind of about it really.
- Yeah, yeah. Exactly.
- But that's most days,
so it doesn't really (indistinct).
(laughing)
One time I went to an
Italian restaurant here,
and you know, I feel like
an Italian restaurant,
I feel like you can almost judge it
on how good their
espresso is with the meal.
- Yeah, of course.
- It must end on an espresso.
I feel at least like, you know?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- And you know,
it was pretty good food
and I was like, not bad.
- Have you found one
that has a good espresso
'cause I've yet to find one yet?
- There's one or two that if I see
the actual espresso machine
in the back, I'm like, nice.
You know it's gonna be good.
'Cause they've gone to the effort,
to get this ridiculous expensive machine,
just for this like one part of the meal.
- Right, right, right.
- But I was eating there and
the food was pretty good.
I wasn't disappointed and
I thought, well fantastic.
I'm gonna end my meal
off with an espresso,
and it said on the menu, it said espresso.
And it was a double or a single.
And so I ordered the double espresso,
and they just brought out
essentially an Americana.
- What?
- And I said, like,
oh no, no, I ordered the espresso.
And they're like, "Oh no,
no, that's the espresso."
And I'm like, what?
It's like this tall.
I'm like, that's not an espresso,
and if it is, I'm gonna
be having a heart attack.
- It's like a triple, double espresso.
- I'm like, what?
Am I the asshole here?
Are you gonna make me pay for this?
I'm not paying for this.
I paid for it, but you know. (laughs)
- I didn't walk out.
- And naturally I didn't complain,
and I paid for it, but
that's not the point.
I mean, I was very disappointed-
- Was it at least a good Americana?
- No, it was awful.
- No, fuck.
- That day onwards,
I swore against ordering coffee in places
where I couldn't visibly
see an espresso machine
in their establishment.
I'm like take me to the
back, take me to the back.
Let's see what's going on, come on.
- Yeah 'cause I'd say the best
purchase I've made in Japan
by none is the Nespresso machine.
- I'm gonna get that soon.
- I would trade my first born
son for a Nespresso machine,
honestly, straight up.
Like that thing, I hug
that thing every day,
I give it a morning kiss.
I could go homeless and the
one thing I'd keep with me,
is the Nespresso machine.
I'd be going around on the street
holding the Nespresso machine,
plugging it into outlets
when I can just to get a coffee.
- This episode of "Trash
Taste" is sponsored by Honey.
- [Connor] We all shop online,
and we've all seen that promo code field,
taunt us at the checkout.
But thanks to Honey manually
searching for coupons,
is a thing of the past.
Honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one
it finds to your cart,
and Honey supports over
30,000 online stores!
- That's a lot of stores.
- It's more than I can count.
- All right, here how it works gentlemen.
- Break it down.
- Imagine you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites.
- I'm there.
- When you're at the checkout,
the Honey Button drops down,
and all you have to do
is click apply coupon.
- That's so simple.
- [Joey] Wait a few seconds,
as Honey searches for coupons
it can find for that site.
And if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch the price drop.
- That's it?
- It's as simple as that.
- That's it.
- Gentlemen, gentlemen, trade offer.
You get savings, you get free app.
I get Honey.
- Tell me, gentlemen, what
have you saved on Honey?
- Recently Garnt,
I bought some gym clothes
that I saved about $10 on
and I haven't used them yet,
and I probably won't be
using them 'cause it's summer
and I'm not gonna go outside.
- But at least you saved
some money with Honey.
- At least I saved some
money guys, cue credits.
- Honey is found it's
over 17 million members,
over $2 billion in savings.
What are you waiting for?
If you don't already have Honey,
you could be straight up
missing on free savings.
It's literally free to install,
and it only takes a few seconds.
And by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a favor,
and also supporting us.
- I'd never recommend
something I don't use.
- Get Honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Back to the episode.
- Yeah, speaking of coffee machines,
I found this fucking.
So like, Aki is quite
obsessed with TikTok,
as most people are these days.
And I don't have like,
'cause I don't have TikTok
installed on my phone, right?
My only exposure to TikTok
is watching with Aki.
And there's this fucking thing where,
you know those like TikTok stories like,
Amazon gadgets that
changed my life, part 71.
Like, you know those, right?
They all sound the fucking same.
There was one where it was literally
this alarm clock, all right?
400 bucks.
It was this alarm clock that
makes you a cup of coffee.
- Oh we had that.
- When it went off.
- Yeah, we had that in the
'80s in the UK for tea.
- Really?
- Yeah, it was called
a Kettle Mate.
And you could set the alarm,
and it would pour a cup of tea for you
when the alarm went off.
This is not a new invention TikTok,
fuck you.
- Yeah, yeah.
So there's like a fucking,
it looks like, maybe it's about that big.
- That's pretty massive!
- It's pretty fucking large,
but there's like the cup,
the coffee mug there,
and then there's like a proper
brewing thing on the side.
And you put in this like
canister of milk in the morning,
and then like lock it in.
And when the alarm goes off,
it just straight up just
makes you a fucking like-
- The Nespresso machine
is literally one button.
(laughs)
You could literally have
that next to your bed.
You don't need like-
- Yeah, exactly.
That's what I was thinking.
I was like, just get a
fucking Nespresso machine,
and just put the fucking
thing in and, yeah.
- Nespresso, please just
sponsor us already, please.
- 'Cause the problem is
I feel like Nespresso
is one of the best capsule machines,
but I feel like in Japan,
it's the only capsule machine
that is actually good.
- Because like you could get
like the actual, you know,
the ones that actually have to put,
the coffee grinded beans.
- The beans.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But like I had one of those.
- [Garnt] I had one of those as well.
- Cleaning it is such a pain in the ass.
Like Nespresso is like the perfect brand.
I'm literally just fucking
marketing for you right now.
It is literally the easiest
and like easiest to clean.
It's just easy.
- Fully sponsored.
- For the quality you get
and for the convenience,
it is the best capsule machine-
- Please sponsor us.
- That I have owned.
And I have owned a lot
of capsule machines.
(laughing)
- We bought one just for this office.
'Cause we were like we want-
- It was literally the
first purchase that we made.
And we tried to get GeeXPlus
to pay for it for us,
but they wouldn't allow
it, so we paid for it.
- Before we bought this table,
we bought the Nespresso machine.
(laughing)
- We had our priorities
right, that's for sure.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, I remember
when they gave us the
spreadsheet of just like, okay,
so they get it's like
GeexPlus gave us a spreadsheet
'cause they said they would help us,
not decorate the office,
but furbish the office.
And we were like, okay,
tables, desk, television,
not microphones.
- Nespresso?
- [Meilyne] Machines.
- No, no but it was split up in like
here's the list of the things we need
and here's the list of the things we want.
And we put Nespresso machine
in the first thing on need.
(laughing)
We're like no, no you
don't understand Geex,
we need this.
It's not a want.
- And Meilyne was like,
"Do you really need this?
Is this as necessary as the table?"
And we're like, yes, without coffee,
this podcast is not happening.
No, I'm sorry.
- I'm not gonna film.
- Yeah, I refuse to release episodes.
- 'Cause like another thing about Japanese
is like coffee shops as well,
is that there are so many
independent coffee shops here in Japan.
So if you're ever coming to Japan,
you can walk down a random
street and find like five to 10
different indie coffee shops.
And the problem is they
all look fucking great.
- [Connor] Yeah, they do.
- But it's such a coin flip,
on whether it's going to
be good coffee or not.
'Cause like the fallacy is that
some of the best and
poshest looking coffee shops
I've been to in Japan, have
had just the shittest coffee.
- Yeah, it's like acid.
- [Garnt] Yeah. (chuckles)
- It's like dirt water.
'Cause I remember like,
especially in like Central Tokyo,
like (indistinct) and like
Kichijoji and stuff like that,
there's a lot of really like fancy,
kind of like rustic looking coffee shops,
where there's like the
beans are all lined up and-
- They've got the aesthetic down.
- They've got the aesthetic to a T.
- Yeah.
- And then you order in,
and you're like waiting
for this cup of coffee
for like 20 minutes.
And you're like what are they picking,
the fucking coffee beans off the plant?
It's taking so long.
And what comes out is like shit.
- Yeah.
- Essentially.
- It's just like dirt water, sometimes.
- It's like $12 please.
- Yeah and it's fucking
$12 for like this one,
I thought you like,
'cause especially going
to America or something,
you order like a cup of coffee,
and you just assume that
it's refillable, right?
It's that kind of level of quality.
But in Japan you can have like
the fucking instant coffee,
dirt water and they give it to you
in this like the poshest little cup,
and it's fucking tiny, it's $12.
And you're just there being
like, I'm even more depressed
than I was before I ordered this coffee.
- That's why it's sad, right?
It's sad that like Blue
Bottle Coffee and Starbucks,
are like the best coffee in Japan.
- It is.
- It really is.
- It's like going to any foreign country,
but like, you know, McDonald's
is the finest cuisine here,
it's literally the best.
Like don't eat anything else.
Like it's so sad having to be like,
the foreigners did it better than you,
and they're fucking chains.
- Just like, oh, you want
some good fried chicken?
Well, I know a place.
It begins with a K. (laughs)
- It's got my favorite
Colonel in front of it.
(laughs)
- It feel like you're admitting defeat,
where like the big corporations
are the best at something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, right.
But like that's what I mean,
when I say we truly do
live in a tea society,
because like they'll do green tea.
- Tea here's amazing.
- Tea is fucking great.
- The tea here
is fucking great.
The green tea is obviously,
but like the other types of
tea here, fucking fantastic.
But it just take you a little bit longer
to perfect the coffee, I feel.
- Although, I will say
there's some teas here
where they're like, yeah,
it's just like cherry flavor
and I'm like, I do not
taste any tea in this.
This is just cherry.
They're like sweet teas
where I can't taste the tea.
And I'm like, what's the point in this?
I'm just not a tea drinker, so.
- Oh, I love tea.
- I only drink tea when
I have afternoon tea.
I don't know.
I don't drink tea.
I guess Japanese tea is different, right?
'Cause when I think of
tea, I think of hot tea.
- Yeah, yeah, I think
of like an Earl Gray,
or like a English breakfast,
and like that kind of stuff.
But like, yeah, I don't count green tea
like an afternoon tea, tea.
- I think afternoon tea
is probably the only good
British export that we've done.
- It's a British export that I'm proud of.
- Yeah. yeah.
- Is there really nothing else?
(laughing)
I'm like racking my brain.
I'm like there has to be something else,
right?
- Well, what else is there?
- Stealing? I don't know.
Like we stole a lot of stuff.
- Pillaging.
- Tuesday?
- Tuesday. (laughs)
- Tuesday.
- Tuesday, YouTube.
- A part of me dies inside
whenever I go to like a restaurant
that does like foreign,
like European cuisine,
and I see fucking fish and chips there.
I'm just like, why are you
selling fish and chips?
- The best fish and
chips though I ever had,
was this British pub,
British Irish pub called
Hobgoblin in Shibuya.
- You mean ever?
It's the best fish and chips-
- No, no, no, in Japan, in
Japan, in Japan, obviously.
- No, yeah.
- In Japan.
'Cause every other fish
and chips I've had is like,
they vinegar the fuck out of the fish,
where it's just like I'm not eating fish,
I'm eating solid vinegar-
- No, they should let you
put the vinegar on yourself.
- Yeah.
- Yeah but, right.
But there's places where
they just like do it for you,
- That's fucked up, that's not right.
- So like the is like inside
the fucking meat of the fish.
And I'm just like, this
does not taste like fish,
It tastes like vinegar.
As much as I love vinegar,
don't get me wrong.
- What's the maximum you'd
pay for fish and chips?
- Abroad or in England?
- Let's just full stop.
- I mean, how big are we talking?
- Like a normal portion,
- Like a normal port, like that?
- That's why I was like, you know,
when I went to this place-
- Like 15, no.
- The most?
- That's what I mean, right?
They charge me $22.
I'm still angry about this, by the way.
- $22 for a fish and chips.
- $22 and it was mid chip, honestly.
It was not very good.
- Wait, was that
at the Welsh place?
- Yeah, it was at the Welsh town.
- Oh Yikes!
- I'm sorry,
I feel like I'm like
completely ruining their like
any foreign tourism they get now,
but that fish and chips was abhorrent.
And they increased the price.
- Welsh town reviewed by a Welsh man.
- I'm still annoyed about it, $22.
- 22 bucks is pretty ridiculous.
- My mom, she'd probably slap me
if she saw that I've
handed money for that.
It was like a five pound
fish and chips as well.
It was not my chip-
- Was it like a frozen
Iceland fish and chips, then?
- It wasn't good.
It was like more batter than fish.
- That's what I've noticed
whenever I've tried fish and chips
that have not been from England.
Even in England, not every
fish and chips you get
is fucking good, anyways.
- A lot of them are shit.
A lot of them are really shit.
- I'd say 80% of fish and
chips you get in England
is shit anyway.
So why would I trust
it outside of England?
- That's why you gotta go to a nice pub,
a nice fancy kind of pub
that just like focuses on food a lot,
and they'll have fish
and chips on the menu.
It'll probably be fucking banging.
They might have like triple
deep fried fries, as well.
- Honestly, I wanna take
you guys to the Hobgoblin,
'cause it's like a proper
barramundi fish and chips.
- I mean the best fish and
chips I've had, is in Brighton
And it's like-
- Is that the one you took us to?
- Bankers?
- I believe so.
- I can't remember.
Probably.
- Probably, yeah.
- Did you say you live
next to a fucking ocean.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's 'cause we live
next to the fucking sea, right?
So that's like, it's good fish and chips,
because the fish is just fresh,
and you can taste that
it's fresh and it's like-
- Yeah, the one you took us to in Brighton
was easily the best fish and
chips I've ever had, yeah.
- But like even so like there's something,
I feel weird whenever like,
you go to Japan and people like,
yo, you can try the ramen,
you can try the sushi,
you can try all these different cuisines.
And someone visits me in fucking England,
and I'm like, yo you wanna
get some fish and chips?
Go to a local chippy, go to
a pub, and I'm just like.
- That's where you're going wrong.
You immediately have to get them drunk,
so that they can't like,
(laughing)
so they don't focus on the food-
- They can't judge correctly.
- Yeah that's what I do.
I'm like, let's go to
the pub right away, yeah,
We're four beers in, you
won't care what we're eating.
- But like the problem is when they stay,
they're staying for like a week, right?
Like how many days in a
row can they drink alcohol
before they've realized it.
- Tesco meal deal.
(laughing)
- I'm gonna blow your mind
with a Tesco meal deal.
- Before they realize
that there's just not much
to our culture that we can
show off to like tourists
that visit us.
That's what I think.
- I mean, it's the same
problem in Australia as well.
Like, after you have a kangaroo steak,
there's literally nothing else.
'Cause we have fish and chips
as well, but like not as good.
- Cause I think the one
thing I've realized,
after moving to Japan or after
moving outside of England,
and living in places
like Thailand and Japan,
and stuff like that is that,
to me in England there's not much to do
apart from drink, right?
If you don't drink-
- Is that what happens
when you live in a place,
or is that what happens
when you like leave it,
and are aware?
Like I wonder, cause like do you know
what there's much to do in,
is there much to do in
Australia that you know of?
- Other than going to the
pub and going to the beach,
not really.
- It's depressing, innit?
- At least we have really
nice fucking beaches,
from where I'm from.
- At least you got that, we
don't even have nice beaches.
Like I am from-
- My beach is very nice.
There's plenty of free needles
and trash and everything.
- I tell people I grew up in
a beach town, a beach city.
It's Brighton.
- Brighton's shit.
- Yeah, we have pebble,
like Brighton is the tourist
beach in England, right?
And it's like the worst
beach I've ever been to.
- It's just rocks.
- And I say that as someone
who grew up in Brighton.
I'm born and bred in Brighton,
and I'm just like, it's just
a bunch of fucking rocks.
You can't even go there barefooted, right?
- And to make matters worse,
Brighton is just as expensive as London.
So like what's the point
of like (indistinct)?
- It wasn't always like that.
- You're like they gentrified my area!
- I remember a time
when Brighton was cheap.
- You know, the way you can tell,
and this is like,
I don't know if this is
scientifically proven,
but as far as I'm concerned it is,
you can tell the costs
of a town in the UK,
100% just go to the pub,
see how much the beer is?
If you see, yeah,
go to any pub,
- One pint.
One pint.
- How much is like the middle
of the like price, like pint?
How much is it?
- Right, right, right.
- Cause in Brighton,
it's like what, like four
pound fifty, maybe five pounds?
- Four pound, five pound.
- It's like London prices.
- That's on the expensive end.
Where I'm from, it's like two pound 20.
- Yeah.
- Oh, shit.
- I talk to people though,
that are from the north,
or from Wales or something,
and they tell me about these
magical (indistinct).
- Magical prices?
- These magical two-
- Mythical prices.
- These magical two-pound prices.
- It sounds like two pound 80.
- These magical two pound pints,
and I'm just like, what
land are you from, sir?
- Are you sure that's beer
that you're drinking there.
- I'm sorry, I didn't know-
- [Connor] Also.
I'm sorry, I didn't know you
grew up in fucking Narnia.
What is this magical land that
does not exist in England?
- Bullshit, it doesn't
exist, I don't know.
And then like also to Americans as well,
a pint is, not an American pint,
it's different to American
pint, which is also,
American pint is the biggest
scam ever, by the way.
You guys got ripped off.
I don't know why when Americans
took the pint from us,
for some reason they made it smaller.
- We talked about this on the stream,
didn't we?
- Did we? Oh okay.
- Yeah, I'm pretty sure we did.
It's like a hundred milliliters less.
You're losing a lot of
beer there for no point.
- It's the one time when
Americans took something
and made it smaller.
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- It's like 430 milliliters,
I think around that America,
and British pint is 568 milliliters.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, you get a lot of
beer for like really cheap.
It's like the pint where
I grew up, it's like $4.
- Fuck.
The pint where I grew up was $9.
- That's US?
- Australian.
- Wait's that in like real money? (laughs)
- In real money?
It's nine dollar-ee-dos,
so what's that in USD?
It's like $7 in US?
- That's not too bad.
That's about London prices then?
- Yeah, it's probably
about London prices, yeah.
- I feel like growing up
in the south in England,
whenever I travel, like further north,
and I see the prices, it's
just like I feel great
because no matter where I go in England,
I'm paying either the same
amount, or less than I'm used to.
- This is why probably Swiss people
feel like the most
superior people on earth,
'cause everywhere they go
it's just like on sale.
Like everything is cheap.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, that's why Australians
love coming to Japan.
They feel so rich.
- What do you mean it's only $1 for water.
- Yeah, exactly.
Well, I mean, like remember,
I found that fucking Izakaya Shibuya,
where on I think Tuesdays
it's not even a happy hour,
but like all night it's 50 yen beers.
- You put it like when you
go to places like that,
the beer sometimes doesn't taste right.
- Really?
- I don't know if it's like
the psychological effect of me thinking
this is too good to be true.
- Right, right, right.
- But I find when the beer
is mega cheap at these places in Japan,
it tastes like water.
- Yeah, but after 10 of
them, you don't care.
- I guess, yeah.
- I mean, like for me,
I remember going back to when
we came here as a tourist,
I'm just like, I'm gonna go to
these fucking cheap izakayas
every fucking day.
I'm gonna take advantage of this-
- All you can drink?
Oh my God.
- Like Nomihoudai.
Like all you can drink
fucking every weekend.
Izakaya, let's go guys.
And now I'm just like, ah.
- And then corona was like, "No, no, no."
- But also I just don't
wanna be in pain every week.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But now like, now
that you're living here,
you just feel like there's
so many other cool bars,
and other cool places you can go to
that izakaya just feels like-
- I also rarely drink to
get drunk anymore, right?
I feel like that's like,
I normally get to the
tipsy point and I'm like,
all right, I'm done.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- It's also like-
- I wanna be able
to function the next day.
So I'm like, I'm okay now.
- We're too busy.
- Yeah, basically.
- No, 'cause now I see Nomihoudai,
and I'm just like, ah,
well I could drink as much as I want,
but do I need to anymore?
- And then there's
always the thing of like,
all right, I've been
drinking beer all night.
Do I really wanna swap to like spirits,
and am I really, I don't know.
I don't wanna chug beer either.
I wanna like, like myself.
- I remember the first
time I went to an izakaya,
and they were like would
you like just Tampin,
like just one by one or
do you want Nomihoudai?
And the part where I was like,
I think I'll just go Tampin tonight.
Somewhere inside my head,
I was like, you've changed.
(laughing)
How dare you?
What happened to you, man?
You used to be cool.
Like if you were asked Nomihoudai,
not even a moment of hesitation,
you'd be like, of course, Nomihoudai.
- Yeah like I had the
exact same moment as well,
when I'm just like, I
remember thinking to myself,
whenever I move to Japan, I'm
never not going to say no.
Me say no to all you
can drink beers, really?
And now I'm just like, ah
really, all you can drink?
- I forget you're 30 Garnt, fuck man.
I feel like I'm gonna be so
much worse than you at 30.
I'm gonna be like fucking
awful to hang out with-
- Is it true that like your
entire view on everything
just changes the moment you hit 30,
'cause that's all I've been hearing about.
- Is it true you become a
fucking boomer when you get 30?
(laughing)
- I mean, no.
- You just start hating
every young person.
- No because like,
I've heard from so many people
who are now in their 30s,
where like, it's literally,
I don't know if it's like-
- I identify as a 30-year-old.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- When does the dust start forming?
- I don't know if it's
like placebo or whatever,
or the way you just like overthink it,
but so many people are like,
yeah, the moment I hit 30,
it's just like everything,
like I just stopped
giving a about so much.
- I mean, I feel 30.
(laughs)
- I'm the opposite, I
don't feel 30 at all.
Honestly, I don't feel like
I've changed much at all.
- You haven't.
(laughing)
I wonder how you can
do like, I don't know,
I feel like I'm struggling
to keep up sometimes,
when people wanna party and I'm like,
fine, I'll go to the party.
- No I'm right there as well.
- And I'm like, I'll
force myself to drink,
but half the time my heart's not in it,
you know what I mean?
My heart's not there.
- And I'm still up there like
fucking 5:00 AM or whatever.
- I'm like always in bed by like three now
and Garnt will be like, "Yeah,
I stayed up until 9:00 AM
and I started just doing work at 10."
- You're up till three, dude.
It's like 11:30 and I'm like all right,
I'm gonna go to bed, man.
- Joey's napping in the karaoke place.
- Yeah, I'm like a 60-year-old.
- Yeah.
It's just a sad life.
- Yeah, I don't know like,
I don't feel like I've changed at all.
I'm almost 31 now and I
feel like I just like,
I feel like I'm still fucking 25, 23.
- I mean you still look 25.
- You're gonna be like that
fucking old anime character
that's like the most fun to hang out with.
And he teaches you some cool shit,
and then he sacrifices
himself casually later on.
- You're gonna be the old man
who like looks really small,
but the moment it takes the
shirt off he's just jacked.
- Netero. Basically Netero.
- From what I've heard
from just other people
that are just older than me,
they just told me that your
30s is just basically your 20s,
with one de-buff to your body.
And I guess my hang-overs-
- What's the de-buff for you?
- I guess my hangovers
are slightly worse now,
that's the only reason.
The only reason, like I drink
a fuck ton more wine now.
'Cause I don't know what it is.
It's funny, right?
'Cause when when I was like 18
to like 20, 30-
- Anytime you turn 30 you go,
you're like beer, vodka, nah.
Me moment you turn 30, have a wine cooler
and it's fully stocked.
- That was exactly me when I was 30.
I'm just like, yes, I only drink wine now,
thank you very much.
Beer? Ugh!
Get that teenage shit out of here.
- The next step is gonna
be like wine Cognac
for me please.
(laughing)
- Yeah. I don't know.
I drink wine because,
one, I like the taste,
and two, because for some
reason the hangovers for wine,
are just like way more bearable.
- I remember 'cause like, yeah, exactly.
When I was in my teens and like
early 20s, I was like, wine?
Fuck you.
- I would get the worst hangovers on wine,
especially red wine.
I swear I had like fucking
Vietnam flashbacks,
from drinking red wine
at university, right?
- Thai man (indistinct).
(laughing)
- Like the hangovers there
were like fucking unbearable.
And then I hit like 27, I'm like,
ooh, this kind of feels warm and fuzzy.
- I don't even have
those like Nam flashbacks
'cause like I didn't even
like, I didn't even drink wine.
- You're just making that a thing.
(laughing)
- 'Cause I wasn't even
interested in drinking wine
in my early 20s 'cause my dad is like
a fucking heavy wine drinker.
So he's always like
try this nice red wine.
- He was Australian?
- Yeah, of course, all Australian's
love their wine, right?
Yeah, they all love their wine, so like-
- There's loads of wine
grown in Australia.
- Yeah absolutely.
There's great wine, now, you know,
now that I can drink wine,
it's like, oh yeah, this
is fucking fantastic.
But when you're like 21, 22
and you drink a glass of red,
you're like, oh God, like I can
not get used to this at all.
- Maybe we drink more wine
if we grew it in the UK.
But unfortunately the only
place they make wine in UK,
are prisons, I don't really
think we have too much choice,
of good wine selection.
- I think UK does make some wines.
- Is that wine?
Is that considered wine, or
is that just like grape juice
with attitude?
(laughing)
- As well, you just get
it from France, right?
So once you make your own wine,
everyone's gonna be like,
we literally have France,
like an hour, why would you.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I didn't realize how lucky I had it,
until I moved to a
country that is not well,
I mean, they produce Sake
here, they do produce wine,
but it's not as well known.
I didn't know how good we had it,
where you can just go to
a fucking local Co-op,
or Tescos and buy great wine
that is like triple the
price here in Japan.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it tastes-
- Yeah, wine kinda sucks here.
- That's the problem, right?
You have to go to like
a specialist wine place,
'cause like, if you go to
fucking FamilyMart or Seven,
it's like, you're just
basically picking poison
if you drink the cheap wine here.
It's basically just bottled rat poison.
That's how I see it.
- It's grape flavored hand sanitizer.
- We have such first-world problems.
(laughing)
We just like concerned about
the quality of the wine
that we (indistinct).
Listen, what happened to us, man?
- I don't know, man.
I would say I started
drinking way more wine,
because of corona,
and because when you're stuck inside,
you gotta find an interest
in something right?
- You gotta make your own fun.
(laughing)
- It's just like a narrator.
It's like, "Garnt decided
to take up a new hobby,
alcoholism"
(laughs)
- No, but like it's incredible,
because it's the first time
ever where I drank something,
like a heavy, heavy amount,
and I wake up the next
morning, I'm like, I'm alive.
- That's the thing, right?
Is that I feel like
that's a one-off, right?
I feel like that's being shot,
and it misses a vital organ.
That's what, when you drink and-
- No, no.
- No, no, no.
It's happened multiple times.
- For me, if I just stay on wine,
and I don't mix drinks,
wine hangovers are the most bearable.
- For me it's like beer is
like always worst stomach ache-
- It's gin for me.
- Sake,
- Gin I don't get bad hangovers.
- Always the worst headaches.
- Sake, so like, hangover tier list, okay.
- Hangover tier list.
- Hangover tier list, let's go, okay.
So right at the top, I
don't fuck with this at all.
Sake.
- Sake, yeah hands down, yeah.
- Like so-
- Wait is S tier here
the strongest?
- S tier is like the shit,
like the worst hang over.
- Or should we do the opposite, like?
- Yeah it should be the opposite.
- Okay, well, Sake is like fucking Z tier.
Like I remember like when
Chris was last on this podcast,
we went to the izakaya afterwards.
- Just like one shot of Sake's
enough to give me a hangover.
- Really?
- If I'm drinking something else,
but Sake has even entered my body once,
it completely contaminates my body.
It's like fuck you, Connor.
- Yeah, I remember when
we went to the izakaya,
like literally the hour afterwards.
And I was on beer the entire night,
and then Chris was just like,
"Let's get some Sake, right lads?"
And I remember having like one cup of Sake
and then I was just
like gone the next day.
I don't know why.
- I could see your brain
powering down, as you drank it.
It's like. (mimics powering down)
- He had the audacity to be
like, this is great Sake.
It wasn't great, it was fucking awful.
I've had good Sake that
was just slightly bearable
and this shit was awful.
Tasted like, just something
going off in your mouth.
Like it was something just going stale,
and would hit your body terribly.
Be ashamed of yourself, Connor.
- Yeah, I've never had
worse headaches in my life
after a night of just drinking Sake.
- Yeah.
Sake is by far the worst.
- Tequila's up there.
Tequila's there as well for me.
- Just above that is like,
all the fucking spirits-
- Spirits.
- The really shitty.
- Tequila's the worst one.
- I say tequila's the worst one, yeah.
- I would say tequila and Sambuca,
are like on that level, right?
- I feel bad for like our Muslim fans
that can't watch this, now.
(indistinct)
(laughs)
I wouldn't know anything.
- I'll take your word for it.
- Just trust us. Just trust us.
- 'Cause like tequila and
Sambuca for me are like,
they're the student shots.
They're what you get as a student because-
- Fucking Sambuca?
Who drinks that all night?
Fuck that, psychopaths drink Sambuca.
- What even is Sambuca?
- Exactly, you don't know it.
- Yeah I don't even know it.
- It's a one drink that your mate is like,
"Yeah, let's get this drink."
And then you have it
and you're like (gags).
Like that.
- What is it?
- It's like a licorice.
- Yeah, it's fucking awful.
- Oh, is it like Jaeger?
- Oh, I was about to okay, going on the-
- It's just the same level.
- On the same level,
but like going above that I
would say is Jaeger, right?
'Cause they're all like,
they're all the shots
where you know you wake up
and you can pinpoint the exact
moment the night went wrong.
It was the exact moment someone ordered
a round of Jaeger shots. or
a round of Sambuca shots,
or tequila shots.
- Right, right, right.
- And for some reason,
Meilyne fucking loves tequila and-
- I will never understand that.
I will literally never understand that.
- [Meilyne] I just like the taste.
- What about the taste?
- [Meilyne] No I don't like the taste.
- You don't like the taste?
- Well then why do you drink it?
- [Meilyne] I like how it makes me feel.
(laughing)
- There's other alcohol
you can use that for.
- That's a concerning sentence.
- [Meilyne] It makes me very,
you know. (laughs)
- No we don't
because we can't relate.
- Drunk.
- 'Cause it tastes like ass,
and like the first, I mean, look,
the only time where I was like, okay,
tequila was kind of fun.
It's like the first time you do
with the whole salt thing, right?
- Yeah.
'Cause that's like-
- Cannot the whole salt thing.
- That's so unlike me.
- It's like playing a mini game
while you're doing (indistinct).
- It's like a little event, right?
- I've realized if you're like a student,
which is like when you start
trying all these drinks,
if you had some kind of
fucking quick time event to it,
drinking becomes like 10 times more fun
'cause you're a fucking idiot.
- Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Like there was a,
fuck in Swansea when I went to university,
there's this one bar that would
do these drinks of Sambuca,
where they would light it on fire,
and then like put the like-
- Oh, gas chamber.
- Yeah, that's what it's called,
which is not a very flattering name.
It's called a gas chamber,
which is a terrible name.
And so they would do it for
like one pound 50, right?
Which is like $2.50?
- I didn't know it was
legal in the UK 'cause-
- I don't know if it is,
but they served it to me.
- 'Cause the only time
I've been able to do that,
is not in the UK, but it's
when we go on like fucking-
- It might be illegal,
but you know how the bars are in the UK.
Some of them are (indistinct).
- You know how are the bars are.
- You know how some of
the student bars are.
It feels like it's like World War III
in some of these bars.
Like people throwing up everywhere.
They're serving drinks to
people they shouldn't be.
But yeah, they would
light the Sambuca on fire,
and put a wine glass over
to extinguish the fire.
- I've seen those, yeah.
- Yeah, and then they
would put the wine glass
on the table really quickly,
and then you would shot the thing,
and then you have to breathe in the fumes
from the wine glass.
And it would go straight to your head.
- [Garnt] Yeah, like you know the-
- I've done those before, okay.
Okay, I've had Sambuca before then, yeah,
- Its fucking awful.
- You know, these are like
students shots, right?
- Don't do it, don't do it.
It's terrible.
- Because even with tequila,
you lick the salt, do the
tequila and do the lime, right?
Some are like fucking students,
have found a way to make this
like even more messed up,
because-
- Are you talking about,
the kamikaze shot?
- Did you call it the kamikaze
shot or the suicide shot?
- Yeah suicide or kamikaze, yeah.
- Wait, what is this?
I don't know what this is.
- Okay, so the normal-
- It sounds like "Jackass" stunt.
- It is, it fucking is.
So the normal order you go in is that,
you lick the salt, you
do the tequila shot,
and then you suck on the
lime, or the lemon, right?
- [Connor] In that case,
it makes it bearable.
- So, okay, how about this?
How about instead of licking the salt,
you snort the salt.
- Okay, that sounds stupid.
- And then you drink.
- Take the shot.
- You take the shot, and
instead of sucking on the lime,
you just put it in your eyes.
Who the fuck thought of this?
- So I'm thinking about a new challenge,
it's the shit yourself
in public challenge.
Just shit yourself on the train,
and just see how long you can last.
- I had a friend on my 18th birthday,
who did that three times.
- Why?
- Because we were playing
darts and he was like,
he was so fucking cocky about it.
He was like, I'll beat you.
I practice every fucking day.
And I'm like, your like seven shots in,
you're not gonna fucking beat me.
He's like. "Well, watch this."
- I totally understand
why people are like,
"I don't want drinks."
When I hear about this shit.
I'm like why would you?
- Oh, no absolutely, yeah.
We don't encourage viewers.
- This is has always been a
fucking step level beyond me.
- This is like people
who did like vodka shots
through their eyeball.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
(laughs)
- It's just like, what's
wrong with people?
What the fuck is wrong with people?
- You have a perfectly functioning mouth.
Just use it.
Like for me, I feel old whenever,
or maybe I've always been old
'cause anytime I've
heard a story like that,
I'm just like, who the
fuck thinks this is cool?
Do you have brain damage?
It's like what went wrong in your life
to think that doing a vodka
shot in your eye was bad-ass?
- Right, because this
is the aspect I hated
about being in university.
Is that like, they would be like,
"Yeah, so you do the
vodka shot in your eye,"
and I'm like, why?
Then they'd be like, "Oh, 'cause
it gets you drunk quicker."
I'm like this literally
takes five minutes.
- Yeah.
- Just drink it.
And then I'm the fucking
weirdo out of the group
'cause I'm the one who doesn't wanna shove
a fucking vodka in my eye.
I'm the asshole?
- Yeah, next thing you
know, there'll be like,
"Yeah, I took some fucking ethanol,
and I fucking just injected into my veins.
It was fucking rock and roll man.
That was metal as fuck."
And I'm just like, what?
At what point do we acknowledge
that this is just stupid shit,
that no one should be doing?
- As someone who's done
a shoey a couple of times in there life,
I can't really say
anything, unfortunately.
(laughing)
That's probably the most
fucked up one I've done, yeah.
- This episode of Trash Taste
is sponsored by Harry's.
- With Harry's,
you don't have to choose
between a great shave,
and a fair price because you can get both.
- I mean, as you know, boys,
I took that shaving kit home and no joke,
it's the best shave I've had in Japan.
Please send me more razors, Harry.
Please, I legitimately am running out.
Please, send me more.
- And that's the realist promotion,
you will probably ever get-
- I'm actually not joking.
I really want more.
- That's why Harry's is
offering our listeners
a starter set at harrys.com/trashtaste.
- [Connor] Harry's delivers
a close, comfortable shave
at a fair price.
Still as low as $2 a refill-
- Which is ridiculously low.
- That is fucking amazing. (laughs)
- [Connor] Harry's blades
are designed to stay sharp.
In a recent study, guys
who shave four times a week
said their eighth shave was
as smooth as their first.
- Here's how they've done it.
There's no gimmicky features.
The Harry's design team
combined a weighted ergonomic handle
with their signature blade cartridge.
- [Connor] It's a small, simple
razor designed to deliver
a close shave along all
the contours of your face.
- Plus, Harry's stands behind
the quality of the blade so
much that they have a 100%
money back guarantee on harrys.com.
- So what are you waiting for?
Harry's is giving their best offer
to the "Trash Taste" listeners right now.
- [Connor] New customers
can get a starter set,
at harrys.com/trash taste.
You'll get a five blade razor,
a weighted ergonomic handle,
foaming shave gel, and
a travel blade cover.
- That's a $13 value all for just $3.
So there's never been a
better time to try Harry's.
So go to harrys.com/trash taste
to redeem your offer today,
back to the episode.
- Yeah, I just feel
like you can feel, okay.
I'll tell you when you know
you've reached the generation gap, right?
It's that point, because
I remember when I thought,
yeah, I'll always be up for a tequila,
or Sambuca, or Jaeger bomb.
And then somewhere along in life,
I reached like mid 20s and I'm just like,
maybe they're just
better ways to get drunk
other than doing these
shots, I don't know.
- Oh no, you just kinda be like, do I?
Do I wanna be drunk?
(indistinct)
(Garnt laughs)
- I remember I used to think like,
I would look at like all
the dads at a pub, right?
And I'm just like, they're
just sitting there talking
with a beer in their hand?
That doesn't sound fun.
And now I'm just like,
I wish for that more
than anything right now.
That sounds amazing!
- Exactly, right?
Exactly, right?
And I remember thinking like,
when I was in university,
I remember thinking, I'm
never gonna be like that.
I'ma still be doing shots
when I'm 50, let's go.
- I was like that when I was like 22,
I just gave up at like 21.
I was like fine, I
finished with university.
Time to be a fucking-
- Time to be an adult.
- Time to be a boring functioning adult.
Terrible, isn't it?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I remember recently I went to my,
like some of my first wine events.
Went to a wine tasting event,
and that's how you know, that's-
- Privilege.
- That how you know you're making money.
- That I've reached that age
when I'm just like, okay,
how about wine tasting?
- It's like yay!
- And I remember taking Connor
to one as well, one time.
And like, so this one time,
like the people at this wine
event are exactly the people
you expect to be at this wine event.
Everyone's in like their
fucking 40s or 50s.
Everyone's like a fucking
investment banker or something.
Something little-
- With a monocle and top hat?
- (laughs) Yeah, yeah.
That's basically like,
the main guy running the event
is this really old French dude
who you could see in a
monocle and top hat, right?
(Joey laughs)
And I remember, so I was with Sydney.
And so he was, you know, it's
like a very intimate event.
So he would go around
asking people, what they do.
And of course, when they go
to us, we mentioned YouTuber,
and like obviously people
perk the fuck up, right?
And of course, he goes to
Sydney and ask what she does.
And Sydney just very tastefully says
that she does videos
about anime, and manga,
and Japanese culture.
And then he asked her
for her YouTube channel,
and she gives it to him.
- [Connor] No!
- And then he goes, oh,
let me just search this up.
And I've never seen the life
flash before someone's eyes
as fast as I've seen like
Sydney go, "No, no, no, no.
Don't do that, don't do that." (chuckles)
But the best part was, so,
at this wine event, you know,
it's a room full of people.
They are very, very prim
and proper, you know.
It's a very,
I would say it is a very posh room.
- Yeah, yeah. Of course.
- And so we go up to have
like I think like our third
or fourth glass of wine that we're trying.
And so there's this word in
French that means cheers.
- We say it in English as well, though.
- Do you?
- Yeah you say it in the UK
as well.
- Okay, so you know,
it's that joke that the guy
makes every single fucking time,
because it's like a very
obvious joke, right?
So he goes, "Okay, everyone.
Everyone say, chin, chin."
And then the entire room is just silent,
except I just hear next
to me, Sydney go. (laughs)
- Like It is not quiet at all.
She just bursts out. (giggles)
(laughing)
And everyone just starts laughing.
I remember just sitting there like, fuck,
I'm with those guys.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
To be fair, it is pretty funny.
(laughing)
- Yeah, in the UK we go like chin, chin.
- Yeah, chin, chin.
- Yeah it's like drink.
- Did you ever say that?
- Yeah in the UK people
always say chin chin,
like before you down a
pint or something like,
chin chin, and then you down it.
- I've never heard that before.
- Maybe it's like a northerner thing.
I don't know, people always said that.
- They say that in Italy too, don't they?
- Italy as well?
- Yeah, I believe so.
- Maybe that's where (indistinct).
Yeah anyway.
- Cause I remember
the first time I heard it
was when I went to Italy.
- Oh God, we didn't explain the joke.
If you don't know, chin,
chin, sounds like, ochinchin,
which means penis in Japanese.
The more you know.
- So basically
you're just saying pee-pee.
- Yeah, everyone say, "Pee-pee."
- Pee-pee.
- Dick.
(laughing)
- And Sydney of course.
- Everybody.
Penis.
- Being the mature woman,
that she is, just laughed.
- To be fair, the first time I heard it,
I fucking burst out laughing too.
I was like, you gotta be taking the piss.
- 'Cause we're like some
like really fancy hotel
where like there's literally
security every like 10 meters
to check whether you're in the right place
and then Sydney just fucking laughed.
- Wait, what?
- It was in like some fancy hotel.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- I always feel really out of place,
'cause I'm just like a child.
So I'm like-
- Yeah right?
- I'm like, I don't belong here.
- Whenever I go to like
any fancy restaurant,
it doesn't matter where it is,
I'm just like, I shouldn't be here.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I'm in a fucking T-shirt,
and I'm like what's going on?
Fuck it, I'm here to taste
some wine.
- It's like, yeah,
I just wanted wine.
I felt like every time I
go to one of those events
or especially like a company party,
I never feel more self-conscious
than whenever everyone around
me is just wearing suits.
and I'm just like-
- Meanwhile I have to bust
out this fucking wrinkly ass
collared shirt from like
the bottom of my wardrobe.
I was like, oh fuck!
- It's great, you can go to these events
and then people will tell you about
how rich their parents are.
It's really fun, it's really, really fun.
I love it. It's great.
- Great.
(laughing)
- It's just so depressing.
I don't wanna fucking
hear about how your dad
owns ten companies, fuck off.
- You guys should have gone
in fucking the Giorgio suits, right?
You should've just like fully committed,
like proper like, wear a monocle
and like a top hat and everything.
- I don't think monocles
have been in fashion
since the fucking plague.
- You can bring it back.
- Bring it back.
- Yeah, bring back.
- I'll bring back the monocle.
- Bring back the monocle.
- Just cosplay the monopoly man.
- Yeah, exactly. (laughs)
- That's what I'm gonna do.
- Fake mustache and everything.
- I wanna get gray hair so I
can become the monopoly man
before it falls out.
- And drink wine.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Oh, my God.
(laughs)
How the fuck did we get on this topic?
- I don't know, we didn't
address the wine tier,
the hangover tier list.
By the way I'll just do
it for you right now.
Gin is number one, wine is
second, beer is in the middle,
and then all the other weird
spirits sit down below,
and then right at the bottom is Sake.
There you go. Boom!
So then you say we did not
finish that tangent, fuck you.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Onto the next one.
What's the next topic.
- What's the next tangent?
- We on (indistinct) boys, right?
- Evian water spray.
(laughing)
- So, let's explain that.
- Are you talking about,
okay (indistinct).
- Yeah, Let's explain that.
- So, what happened?
- Meilyne is like.
- So yesterday I get this
a very ominous message
from Meilyne, all right, okay.
- When does Meilyne's
messages not ominous?
- Oh, yeah.
- Okay, okay.
- Oh yeah, let me-
- So I get this very
ominous message from Meilyne
just saying, "Hey tomorrow,
can I try something on you
at the office?"
(Joey laughs)
- It's never a good thing
when Meilyne says this.
- What the fuck is
going on here right now?
And she's like, "Yeah, I have
this like ultrasound thing
that I wanna put on your face,"
or something like that.
- It's for the baby, right?
- Is that what that was?
- Yeah, I guess so,
Meilyne, do you wanna explain what it was?
- It's like an ultrasound thing, right?
- [Meilyne] No, it's like
ultrasonic form vibration.
- You're just putting buzzwords together.
- The only time you hear
ultrasonic is in the Sonic game.
That is the only time you hear it.
- That is literally just
a sponsorship script.
It's got ultrasonic buzzword.
- I have it right here.
It is an Evian facial spray.
- This is like wet your face.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- This is to wet your face.
- That's just to wet
my face, where so she-
- How much does this cost?
How much does this cost, Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] I don't know.
- That looks like a vibrator.
- It does look like a vibrator.
- That does.
How much does this cost?
- [Meilyne] I don't
know, I got it for free.
- From who?
- [Meilyne] I don't know.
- From a sponsor.
- Who's giving out Evian-
- [Meilyne] Costco.
- Costco, wow.
- Costco?
I didn't even know they had
Evian water spray before.
So, yeah.
(Joey laughs)
So for some reason I just
agreed to it and said, yes,
do whatever you need to do Meilyne.
And so she puts this gel on my face
and then starts rubbing
that, wait, no, no, no.
First she sprays the Evian facial spray,
which I think is just water.
(laughs)
- It's literally Evian in a can.
- She just sprayed Evian water on my face,
put a gel on it and just
did a fucking ultrasound
on my face.
- That's weird.
- And apparently we are never getting
a sponsorship from Evian ever again.
- It's really just going back and forward,
that's all it's doing.
It's literally, that's all it's doing.
How is that doing anything?
- [Meilyne] You need gel.
- Do you know if I-
- For real? do, I though?
- You do.
- If I actually just got
what, like a pregnancy.
- [Meilyne] No. (chuckles)
- What do you do?
You're like seeing if its face-
- That's what it felt like.
It felt like she was going to like,
she was like fucking doing
an ultrasound on my face.
I wanna start a business
where I just put my mouth
against your cheek and just
scream and call it a therapy.
(laughs)
The vibrations will heal any
kind of impurities you have.
- Yeah, so basically before we started
recording this episode, Meilyne was like,
"I'm just gonna do half of Garnt's face
so that the boys can
see the magic and wonder
of the before and after.
- Could not tell the difference.
- Yeah, we're probably never
gonna get a sponsorship
from Evian, but it
looked the fucking same.
Like the-
- Can you tell the difference in my face
from my usual camera?
- The left side of his face
was just a little bit more
moist than the other side.
That's all it was like. (laughs)
I don't know what this
is supposed to do, but.
- [Meilyne] What?
- It doesn't.
- Does it though, Meilyne,
or are you just led to believe it works?
It's for gullible people who wanna believe
there's a solution for everything.
And sometimes you just ugly.
That's how it is.
That happens.
I gotta deal with that.
No amount of Evian water
spray will save you
from you ugliness.
- No amount of Evian shit
is gonna fucking fix my
problems, you know what I mean?
It's fucked.
That's the thing.
If this truly fixed your
ugliness, no one will be ugly,
'cause everyone would just buy these.
- I will now end world ugliness.
(laughing)
- I tell you, It's been real
quiet since that dropped, man.
(laughing)
- Evian's like, "We're to save the day."
- Oh my God.
- I'm sorry, Meilyne.
- We're about to put
the fashion industry out of business.
Everyone is gonna be a model
after we bring out water
spray to the scene.
- There's so much stuff
like that where I'm like,
I'm sure it works like 0.1%,
but how much is it like
a negligible amount
where you're like, is it worth my time?
How good does it have to be
where I have to sit there
and rub my face and spray Evian on it?
You know what I mean?
How good are the results have to be?
- There're just some
things where it's like,
I get the intent as to
why this was invented.
- Yeah.
- But it's also like,
there are so many other alternatives
that work just as well and
probably a lot cheaper.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Like going back to the whole like fucking
Amazon things you didn't
need, you needed, right?
That is a prime example.
That is just like a bunch of
people with way too much money
who are just going on to Amazon
buying all these fucking things.
I remember those one-
- It's just sad,
'cause I mean, it's just like
they feed off the insecurities
that people have.
- Right.
- They have those weight loss bracelets.
Have you seen those?
- It's probably just a
bracelet that has magnets in it
or something that apparently
will make you lose weight.
And the before and after pictures
are the fucking egregious.
There'll be like the most obese person,
and then apparently because
of this one bracelet,
which they probably can't
even get on their hand
how exaggerated obese he is.
- It starts off as a ring.
- Yeah, it's like apparently
this magically makes you extremely hot.
It doesn't address the problem with,
if you go from like 500
pounds to 200 pounds,
where's the skin gone?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Doesn't address that.
It just magically sucks back in.
Like, fuck off!
- What I love is when you
see the before and after pic
and it's so obviously not the same.
- Yeah, yeah, I love those.
I love those.
- It's just like someone's
so morbidly obese
that they think that because
they now have a six pack,
you can't recognize that
it's just not the same
fucking person.
- Yeah, the lighting
is totally off.
- The belly button's totally different.
Like there's no hair.
- One thing I always find funny,
is like why always in the before pic
does like the camera man, just say,
"Look as depressed as you can."
- It's like a subconscious thing.
- Like you're smiling
Why are you smiling?
This is the before pic.
- Yeah, I mean in the UK
they're just depressed in birth,
but I mean it's like subconscious, right?
If you see someone smiling
you're fucking dumb monkey
brains thing, oh good.
- Yeah.
- That's a good thing.
- Good thing happened again.
- Good thing happened thing.
- Happened thing here.
I don't know, I get really sad when I know
that clearly someone's buying this stuff,
unlike the detox teas
that just making yourself.
It's just like shitting yourself,
of course, you're gonna lose weight
'cause you're shitting out all the stool
that you have in there.
Of course, you're gonna lose weight,
but it's just sad that
people feel desperate enough
and they can't just like
believe the fact that it's like,
just eat less.
- Sometimes it's not that
simple though, I know.
But that's the core of it, though.
- Just eat less.
(Joey laughs)
- Don't get cyber bullied.
Just turn off the PC.
But it suck 'cause-
- Just don't get hungry.
(laughing)
- But that's what it is.
The fundamental of it is
just like eat less shit.
- Obviously, there are
exceptions in there.
Some of you in the comments
be like I have X...
Yeah. Okay, good.
But like the fundamental of it is,
don't buy this bullshit, you know.
- It's so stupid.
- It's like the people
who are buying into that kinda stuff,
usually that's all it is.
And like all they need is
just like a change of diet
or just something so fucking easy.
And yeah, they're just like.
- Just don't be fat.
(laughing)
- Listen, listen.
I can vouch for the
chicken and broccoli diet.
It works. It works wonders.
The chicken and broccoli diet is no joke.
It worked wonders for me.
- A simple payment of 6.99.
- Trade offer.
- You get chicken and
broccoli, you lose weight.
It's simple as that,
literally (indistinct).
- I get 79.99, you get
chicken and broccoli. (laughs)
- Chicken and broccoli
company team up with me.
I will show up, dude.
- Is there a chicken
and broccoli company?.
- There actually is on
Uber Eats around our area,
There is a (indistinct).
- Yeah, yeah.
- I actually ordered it.
- No fucking way.
- It was pretty fucking good.
- There was literally a
chicken and broccoli chain
that just delivers chicken broccoli.
This is how it works, guys.
It's not fun, but weight loss isn't fun.
It doesn't need to be.
- I feel like, I mean,
it's sad that sometimes
in self-improvement,
a big factor in whether
it's gonna succeed or not,
is if you're fucking
enjoying yourself doing it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's unfortunate, right?
But like for me, for
example, going to the gym
versus going to do like a sports
or going to do like another activity,
doing that activity is way more
fun than spending even like,
I could do three hours
or something of a sport
versus 30 minutes on a treadmill,
and I choose like a
three hour sport anytime.
- But that's the thing.
That's why I think
Nintendo is like giga brain
when they're released Ring Fit,
'cause that is literally
the answer to like,
you can lose weight and have fun.
- This is like-
- I say that having never played it.
(laughing)
- It is intact. It is intact.
- But I plan to get it, I plan to get it.
This has been sold out for a while.
- The big problem that we
have been like believing
for so long with weight loss,
and this is mainly like,
I know this is like fucking chemistry,
literally it's like-
- Okay, disclaimer, none of
us are weight loss expert.
- Yeah, yeah, don't Take our advice.
- But it's like, the big companies,
like Coke, McDonald's and all them,
they're like, "Yeah, you
can drink as much Coke.
You can eat as much
McDonald's as you want.
All you gotta do is just exercise.
It's not the food, it's exercise."
And it's like, exercise
doesn't really do that much
for weight loss.
But what I find personally
what exercise does do
is the day when I exercise,
I am vigilant about what I'm eating.
I'm like, no, no carbs here.
No sugar.
- For me the day when I
exercise for some reason,
I just-
- You take care of yourself.
- No, I actually crave healthy foods.
I don't know what it is about,
but if I go to the gym
for an hour, that day,
that day afterwards, I'm just like,
man, I'm kinda just
craving a chicken breasts.
Like fuck this pizza, fuck
the curry or whatever.
But like when I'm just
like being a couch potato,
just like sitting here
all day, you're just like,
ah, I feel like shit, so
I kinda just feel like
I'm gonna eat shit.
- I feel like going to the
gym or like just exercising
in any way you can, it's not
so much the act of losing it.
It's just like the motivation.
- Yeah, obviously it helps general fitness
and being healthy and it's good.
I'm not saying it's bad,
but like I feel like
we have definitely been like believe-
- It's not the cream on the crop.
- Yeah, we've also just been like told
when we were growing up,
well, if you eat 10 donuts,
just burn off the calories
and then boom, no damage.
That's not how it works.
- 10 donuts, 10 kilometers
on the treadmill, right?
- It's just not how it
works, though, unfortunately.
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- Trade off.
- You lose 10 pounds.
- You receive 10 donuts,
I receive 10 kilometers on the treadmill.
- It sucks 'cause it's
like at the end of the day
you could go in the gym and
distract yourself with it,
but it comes to that moment
when you're sitting on the couch
or you're wondering what to eat
and you've gotta just have
the willpower to be like,
(slurps) ah, chicken broccoli.
Fine, fine (indistinct).
- Yeah, exactly.
- It sucks 'cause it's like not fun.
- It is all diet.
I mean, I feel like whenever you do
any kind of self-improvement activity,
it's not the days where you feel good
that's gonna define if
you basically succeed,
is the days where you feel bad
and you're able to push yourself through.
And I say this being like
I've had plenty of times
when I have failed because I felt bad
and I just didn't just,
not even the motivation
to push yourself through,
I just didn't have the self-discipline,
'cause I feel like self-discipline
is way more important
than motivation because
there are gonna be some days
where you are just not motivated
and it's those days where
you can push through.
And I know plenty of people who have,
I'm not one of them, unfortunately.
(laughing)
- It's like as well, I
found that when I was,
it's easy to eat really
healthy for like two weeks,
not easy, but it's doable, right?
But then it's like, all
right, what if you just go
right back to doing what you're doing?
It's like, well, nothing has changed.
- That's when the bounce back happens.
- I mean, that's why I was
just like, what can I cut out
that I can keep out like forever?
So I don't drink like soft drinks ever.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- That one thing
that' like cut that shit.
- Yeah, the last, like, since probably
the beginning of quarantine,
I've just made a conscious
effort to not drink
any fizzy drinks or anything like that.
- It's just shit like that
I don't drink either.
- Tea and water.
Is tea, water, coffee is
all fucking I'm drinking.
- Yeah.
I was lucky enough that
I just never craved soda
or anything in my life.
I've just always grown
up on drinking water.
And it's kind of made
me realize that, man,
the habits you had as a
kid, really it's just like,
it's so much-
- They stick with you, man.
- Yeah, they stick with you.
It's so much easier to learn a
habit once than to unlearn it
and to learn something else.
And I feel like so much
of my life, you're like,
if I had a time machine, if
I could fucking (indistinct)
myself back into like a younger body,
there's so many things I
would do to be like, okay,
you learn this, you learn this
habit, you learn that habit
so you don't have to fucking unlearn it.
- Yeah.
- And like have like a fucking
year of your life being like,
well, I have this habit
that I just had as a kid
and it's kinda fucking me
over and I wanna try and do
something else, but God damn,
this pizza feels so
fucking good right now.
(Joe laughs)
- It's not even like I don't
even eat that shit anymore.
I most certainly do.
I kinda like trying to bounce
it out how much I do eat.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's not like
an everyday thing, right?
- I hate talking about this shit online,
'cause everyone's just a expert about it.
Like in the comments, no doubt,
they'll be like 10 people
would be like, "I'm a nutritionist expert.
I'm here to tell you that
you're totally wrong."
- Yeah.
- 'Cause everyone's got their own opinion
'cause most people have gone through it.
Experience of seeing what's
worked for them and so-
- But that's the thing, it's
what's worked for them, right?
And that doesn't mean
it works for everybody.
- As long as you do it healthy,
You're not starving yourself.
Like you see some people are like,
"Yeah, I lost 10 kilograms in a weekends.
It's like that sounds
like a terrible idea.
What did you do?
That sounds awful.
- That must have been
some painful shit.
- Yeah.
- Shitting that F.
- Yeah, fucking hell.
- Yeah, I feel like it's...
I think one important thing is that,
but just because something
worked for someone
doesn't necessarily mean
it's gonna (indistinct) something else.
And it's really like,
what I found is it's really
a trial, what was it like?
- Trial by fire.
- And error.
- Trial and error.
- Trial by fire.
(laughs)
- You either die or you diet.
You either eat this or you fucking die.
- You try or try dying.
- How about just try starving yourself?
You either lose weight or you die.
- I used to be like fucking
paranoid about like,
well, what's in this thing?
But I just started
thinking like if I just eat
a reasonable amount of
things and exercise,
I think I'll be all right.
And that kinda worked.
(laughs)
I was like carbs?
I eat a lot of carbs, but I
just eat them within reason.
My meals are never too big.
I feel like I eat a fair amount of food.
I feel like when I stopped
giving shit about calories
and stuff like that
and just thinking like,
is this portion stupid?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is this a whole large Domino's pizza?
Should I eat this? Probably not.
So probably not gonna do it.
- But I feel like another
thing is that, I don't know.
Maybe it's just me, but I think
I just enjoy food too much.
- That's the problem.
It's not like I enjoy
eating a lot of food, right?
But we talked about (indistinct).
- I do.
- Yeah.
We talked about enjoying
the little things in life
every now and again.
And for me, like my day is like 70% worse
if I know I don't have a
good meal to look forward to.
- This is why I've just
become an Uber Eats slave
at this point.
I every day order from it now.
- That's the problem, right?
- It's terrible.
- But especially because
like Japan is just the land
of fucking great food
everywhere, food's become a hobby
at this point.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, it is.
- I'm just like if I
don't have a good meal,
it's like I feel empty.
- I just feel sad.
- I feel like my day
is just like, yeah, completely empty.
I feel unfulfilled.
I go to sleep and I'm just like, I'm sad.
I have nightmares. (laughs)
- I had the worst Uber Eats
order of my life the other day.
Oh, it was fucking tragic.
It was like, the pictures looked amazing,
the ratings were good.
It was a pork bowl Butadon.
- Okay.
And it looked very nice,
and this places only did pork bowls.
I thought, great, they
specialize in this one thing.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna be
fucking magical.
So I order it, you know,
it takes a little while.
No, not like crazy amount.
And then, so it gets here.
And it's packaged amazingly.
It looks like they've really
cared about the packaging.
Give you an oshibori.
- Oshibori, yeah.
A wet towel.
- Like an actual, like thick one.
- Oh, like a proper one?
- A thick one.
- Like the rolled up one.
- Yeah, like really thick ones.
And I was like, damn (indistinct).
I was getting really excited for this.
I'm like, hell yeah.
Okay, they give their own chopsticks,
really nice chopsticks as well.
So I open this bad boy up.
Looks pretty good, looks pretty good.
And I'm like, okay, fantastic.
So I dig in and I'm like, oh no.
And I'm like, okay, this part
of the rice is kinda hard.
I was like, all right,
well, maybe it's just this one section.
It happens that it clumps up, right?
And so I hit another part and I'm like,
oh no, this part's hard too.
(laughs)
And then I put it in
another part and it's hard.
And I go, maybe it needs a little force.
Maybe it needs a little.
I pull it apart a little bit.
And I picked this up
with like the whole bowl
and I go to just pick up what I think
is a small amount of rice,
and the whole rice comes out.
I picked the bowl up, the whole
bowl, like formed comes out.
And I, no joke, this is why
I was starting to get a little angry.
I had my chopsticks like this
in my hand like a barbarian
stabbing it and like ripping it apart,
and I couldn't rip it apart.
So I shuffled the meat on top to one side
and this is where I was like barbarian.
I literally tried to grab it with my hands
to see if I could separate this rice.
I could not separate this
rice with like my full grip.
- Was it like not even cooked or what?
I don't know what the fuck they did to it,
and I gave them one stars and I was like,
literally, don't give
me a brick next time.
And they said, sorry-
- It's a literal brick of carbs.
- They were like, sorry,
you didn't like it,
we'll improve next time.
Like, give me a refund.
(laughs)
I couldn't eat it.
I didn't even get a fucking refund.
- Wow.
- They ruined my whole night,
'cause it was like 9:00 PM
and everywhere had closed.
- Oh, no.
- And I was like,
I can't order anything now.
I'm just gonna fucking
eat a sembe or some shit.
- You gotta resort to fucking
convenience store food.
- Yeah, I ate a sandwich
and it was depressing.
You know how depressing it is eating a-
- It's depressing.
That's so depressing
- Eating a-
- A sandwich at 9 PM.
- A large sandwich as a dinner?
Something about it is so depressing.
I don't know why.
- Yeah, I know. I know.
It is-
- A ham sandwich for dinner.
- It is depressing.
- Bon appetit.
- I say, having a meal to look forward to,
I don't even mean like
a five-star gomy meal.
- No, no.
- Just like a good
filling meal, even like
a nice home-cooked meal.
- Just something on a plate.
A decent thing on a plate.
- I tear up when I order
a meal here and it's just-
- Yeah.
I remember, going back to Uber Eats,
I remember there's this
Thai place I order from
whenever I'm like missing
home or whatever, but like-
- It's on the weekend?
- I have no idea.
- It's the really fun.
Oh, I like it.
- It's really fucking good.
I order from them like four times a week.
- Yeah, same.
(laughs)
- It's so good.
- (indistinct) is funny.
- That's a lot of Thai food.
- I never get sick of pad thai.
- But like I get the
craving every now and again,
'cause I'm very picky when
it comes to Thai food.
And my problem with this place is that
they never fucking make it spicy enough,
of course.
- That is true.
There's no spice.
- Right.
- As a Thai person, and I
like every time, every time,
I'm sure they fucking know me by name now,
'cause every time I'm just
like, spicy, please spicy.
- Oh, you put it in like the comments?
- Yeah, I put it in the comments.
I'm like, spicy please and
it's just never spicy enough.
I open it and I could
tell that they put a few
chili flakes on it and-
- Just opens it, doesn't
even smell, it's like, no.
- No, you can-
- Take it back.
- You can tell when someone didn't try
with the spice, right?
It's like there's Thai chilies
and then there's like
chili flakes, and okay.
So like last week, this one time.
I'm just like, let me
try something different.
So I asked for it spicy again, right?
But I don't type it in Japanese.
I type it in Thai.
- Oh.
- Big brain. Big brain.
- Big brain.
- So, I typed it in Thai, okay.
And I remember opening it.
I remember getting the same takeaway box,
opening up this package,
and this thing looked
like it had been cooked
in like the flames of hell, man.
Fucking Lucifer grilled this himself.
I open it and like the chili
to rice ratio was just like,
it was more Chili than rice.
- Would you like rice on your chili?
(laughing)
- Can you copy paste what you sent to him?
I wanna see this.
I wanna try this.
- Yeah, sure.
I'd never been more
happy in my life when-.
- Was it good?
- It was good.
- Damn. Okay, okay.
- 'Cause I ordered the pad krapow
and pad krapow is normally
really, really spicy in Thailand.
And you know it's spicy
when you have to like,
you have trouble finding the
meat through the chili, right?
(Joey laughs)
Because it's like you got the normal meat,
and then you got like the
red and green chili flakes,
and not just chili, just like raw chilies.
And I'm just like (claps)
you're my brother.
Now I know you're a brother.
- Fuck, this is like when we went
to the Indian place near here.
They do like Indian food, you know.
I think we'd always asked
for it really spicy,
like very spicy.
And it was quite spicy,
but it wasn't that bad.
And I think-
- I mean, to you guys' level?
- Yeah, 'cause I mean, you know,
even though I am extremely
white, I love spice
that pretty much cripples me.
And yeah-
- 'Cause to a standard person
like myself, that shit's spicy enough.
- Yeah.
- But to these like,
fucking spawns of Satan, it's like-
- 'Cause in Japan, when
you do you tell them
to make it like 10 or
max, they don't do it.
And the first time we went
there, the first few times,
the person who was cooking,
it's always the same guy,
he didn't actually make it that spicy.
It was kinda like, ooh, ooh.
- It was definitely Japan standards, yeah.
- It was like high end for
Japan standards, I'd say.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then one time, for some reason,
I don't know why he decided this time,
he was like, "Fine, I'm not playing."
- He's like, bet.
- He's like, "Fine, I'm
not playing anymore."
And holy fuck!
(laughs)
This shit is hot.
I got like halfway through
this and I was like,
I'm actually in like severe pain.
Like this is actually brutal.
Garnt couldn't finish it.
- Wow.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
I think it was the one week
where you had to go home early.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So we're in this
Indian place.
- This man dd not play.
- Yeah, he was not playing around.
And I think I could see him like
in the corner of my eye just like-
- He was watching us.
- He was like watching us.
- He was giggling.
- 'Cause we've been there so many times.
We order the same meal every time.
We order like the most spicy option.
And it's just like, yeah.
we finish it.
- It's spicy but its not like.
- It's spicy.
It's a nice tingle on your tongue.
- What if he was like, "All
right, the pussy boy is gone.
I'ma give you guys the real shit now.
- But it was by far the
spiciest meal I've had in Japan.
I could not finish it
'cause it got to the point
where it was just, yeah-
- My mouth got numb
about knit (indistinct).
- Jesus.
What is enjoyable about that, though?
I don't get it.
- I don't know what it is,
because the flavors get
enhanced by just beating
the shit out of it.
- No, I get that
to a certain extent.
But the level you guys have, it,
it's just like, I don't even
know what flavor is anymore.
I mean, I feel like it
depends on the dish, right?
I mean you can go to like CoCoICHI, man,
and so to explain, have we
talked about that before?
- CoCoICHI is like a Japanese curry.
- We have it in America.
- Oh yeah, they do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, and so you can go
to this curry chain in Japan and they have
like a spice scale from one to 10,
and like 10 is the most spiciest.
And I've had the 10
before, and so as Connor.
And for me it was actually
like really spicy,
but it felt like-
- There's no flavor.
It just felt like you're adding spice
for the sake of adding spice, right?
There are some dishes that I
feel are designed to be spicy.
- It's not like flavor
enhanced spice, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just spice for the sake of spice.
- To me a mild curry, a mild
Japanese curry at least,
is as good, if not better,
than some of the spicier versions.
But there are some like Thai
dishes and Indian dishes
and Southeast Asian dishes where I feel
if you don't have enough spice to it,
there's missing a certain kick,
a certain flavor to it.
- Yeah, I get that.
- It brings out a lot of flavors,
and also just a lot of
endorphins from the pain.
- No, I get-
- I'm constantly chasing the high.
- I get the fact of like, you know,
the spice enhances the
flavor and stuff like that,
'cause I've had my fair share
of Southeast Asian food
and stuff like that,
which is quite spicy.
And I'm just like, oh,
this is hard to eat,
but, God damn, this
probably tastes way better
than without the spice.
And then there's your
guys' level of spice.
- See the reason why
I got into spicy food,
cause again, you have to bear in mind,
my parents thought like paprika was spicy.
So when I was growing up, we
didn't really eat spicy food,
but when I started doing YouTube,
I started doing the like fucking
stupid pepper challenges.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I've done it so many
times where I was like,
I could handle the Carolina
Reaper like semi comfortably.
And I was like shit, spicy
food isn't spicy anymore,
'cause I've just been
eating these peppers raw
constantly for fucking YouTube challenges
and Twitch live streams.
So I got to the point
where I was like, oh God,
this is like really good now.
I really like it.
Like having cabaneros on
stuff is like perfect.
- No. See, because like-
- I love that.
- When we're talking about
CoCoICHI levels of spice, right?
'Cause that's the easiest gauge
when you're in Japan, right?
It's like, what level
of CoCoICHI can you do?
You immediately know.
I can now do level three.
- Right.
- But before,
like a couple of years ago,
I couldn't even do level one.
That was back when Joey
was wearing a diaper.
That's when I was wearing a diaper.
That's when I was a true pussy boy..
- I feel like, you need something
You need at least like a two.
- Yeah, right.
But you guys can say that
because you're used to this,
'cause you've been eating it for a while.
- I feel like even some
foods where there's an option
to pick a spicy version,
I don't always pick the spicy version.
It very much depends on the dish
and whether it compliments it or not.
- Right. Right.
I mean now I can do a level
three and now I understand like,
oh, this is actually so
much better with spice
to a certain degree.
But like I had to kind
of slowly trick my brain
into thinking that, right?
Because if you had given me
a level three spicy CoCoICHI
like two years ago, I
would have been like,
what is this shit?
This isn't enjoyable at all.
I seek enjoyment out of my meal
and this was not enjoyable.
I'm in severe pain.
But now I've like slowly
started to appreciate the pain.
- Yeah.
- Right?
(Garnt laughs)
- Joey says getting a level three.
- Yeah.
I say that getting a level three.
But for me that's-
- I'm feeling those endorphins
Love that.
- Yeah, honestly like to me
that's fucking painful,
but like it's good painful.
And like now I'm finally
starting to understand.
I'm like, oh, okay
These like other friends
I knew who could eat
like level seven and eight,
who I just thought were like,
absolutely fucking maniacs.
- Just like the noob anime characters,
like the (indistinct).
- It's like, I kinda get it now.
- After my training, I'm
slowly starting to get it now.
- This episode of "Trash Taste"
is sponsored by Crunchyroll.
- [Connor] This season
Crunchyroll is simulcasting
new seasons of classics
like "My Hero Academia"
as well as fresh titles,
including "To Your Eternity," "Odd Taxi,"
and "Don't Toy With Me, Miss Nagatoro."
And now you can binge all
of digital "Jujutsu Kaisen"
from last season.
- Thank God.
- What are you watching, AnimeZone?
- I'm actually watching
everything you mentioned,
'cause honestly this season fucking slaps.
I could recommend any of these,
but if you want it shortened and dark,
watch "To Your Eternity."
Try watching episode one
and not crying your ass off.
- That sounds amazing.
- As always, you get the
biggest catalog of anime content
with over 30,000 episodes
available at any time
in subs and dubs.
And you can watch titles
for free on Crunchyroll
or try a 14-day free trial
of their premium membership
to skip the ads and access
simulcasting with Japan.
- Follow the link on-screen
or down below in that description
at wwdotcrunchyroll.com/trashtaste.
So what are you waiting for?
Start watching some anime
and then you can come talk
about it on "Trash Taste."
(laughs)
- Well, right there, there's
a (indistinct) right there.
- 'Cause we're not gonna do it.
(laughing)
- Thank you, Crunchyroll for
sponsoring this anime podcast.
Back to the episode.
- Well, it's really weird, right?
Because obviously you grew
up in a Thai household,
eating spiced food all your life, right?
- Yeah.
- And you think I would be the same,
'cause my dad loves spicy food?
You know like the death
sauce that they sell here?
My dad would just put that in meals.
(indistinct)
- It's god stuff.
- Yeah, right?
But to me, I was like,
why are you putting cyanide
in a perfectly nice meal?
- Why would you poison
this meal like this?
'Cause then he would fucking
serve it up to the family.
- Oh my God!
- And we would have to eat it.
- That reminds me.
My older brother, he was
growing Carolina Reapers and-
- Why?
(laughs)
- That's a good question.
- 'Cause like wanted, he likes spicy food.
But one time, this was right
before I moved to Japan,
he gave them to my
parents and just told them
they were like normal peppers.
- Oh my, why would you do that?
That is truly evil.
(Joey laughs)
- That's a true crime story (indistinct).
- Yeah, so what happened was is that,
they were like, oh yeah,
they were saying like,
"Oh, Brett's been growing some peppers
and he's given us some.
So I'm gonna put them in
the stir fry tonight."
I was like, oh, okay, sure.
I didn't know that they were-
- Carolina Reapers.
- They were Carolina Reapers,
or ghost peppers, one or the other.
I mean, they're both fucking-
- They're both fucking hot.
- Bear in mind, my parents do believe
that paprika is spicy, I'm not joking.
My dad watches the podcast.
He'll be like, "You're lying, Connor."
And so they made me, it's the
way they did the stir fries.
They make it and they give it to me first
and then like they make it for my dad
and my mom makes for herself last.
And it's like, this is like
five minutes in between.
So I'm eating this stir fry and I'm like,
I'm getting kinda like.
(laughs)
I'm like, this hurts.
And I'm thinking like, oh, whoa, mum,
what peppers did you use?
- She's like, "Oh, this is your brother.
He grew them and gave them to us."
And I'm like, did he say what
kind of peppers they were?
So, "No, no, he just said he grew them."
And I'm like, they got
a little kick to them.
(laughing)
I was like, I think I
got a bit of kick it.
I'm like (wheezing).
'Cause they put all of them
in, like seven or eight.
- All of them.
- Oh my fucking hell.
- Seven or eight ghost
peppers, all of them.
- Your brother was trying
to kill your parents.
- Yeah.
- My parents didn't know.
They thought they were
like the normal spicy-
- Wait, did your parents eat them?
- Yeah, so what happened next is that,
you know, I warned them.
I was like, I really think,
bear in mind, I'm like, (coughs)
I really think that
you should like go easy
on the peppers on yours.
If you can like kinda get
them out a little bit,
I think you should do that.
Like, "No, no, it's fine,
we've had it before.
We've had these peppers before."
- Pictures taken before a disaster.
- At that point I was like, you know what?
Fine, let's just see what happens.
(laughs)
- Let's just see what happens. (laughs)
- Let's just see how this unfolds.
- So I'm there like literally
like that meme of that kid
with the vein on his forehead
after just eating these peppers,
trying to keep a straight face like.
And my daddy he's about to eat it.
He takes one spoonful and
he's like, yeah. (coughs)
"Wow that's pretty.
(laughing)
That's really spicy, huh, why?" (laughs)
And he just started crying.
I thought it was so funny.
And my mom thought he
was over-exaggerating.
- Right, right, right.
- So my mom is like,
"Oh, I'll try it too."
- Oh my God.
(laughs)
- And my mom starts doing
the exact same thing.
She starts fucking go
(coughs), after like one bite.
And they just couldn't finish it.
They just started drinking
milk for like 20 minutes.
- What do they expect?
- They were just dying.
It was the funniest,
I don't know. (laughs)
- I mean, if I was your parents,
I'd take one look at you
and be like, oh, he's probably
not making this shit up.
- Well, I thought they
thought I was exaggerating
with how much spice I could deal.
And I was texting my
brother after I ate a bite.
I was like, what the
fuck are these peppers?
What peppers are these?
What are these, habaneros, ghost peppers?
And he's like, "Oh, Carolina Reaper."
I'm like, why would you
give them to my parents?
You know they can't eat these.
(laughing)
- Your parents, is just
(indistinct) innit?
(indistinct)
- Casually killed mum and dad.
(laughs)
- Your parents trusted you too much.
- I think from that point I would say
I just never accepted any
peppers from my parents,
'cause-
(laughing)
- I wouldn't.
Fucking hell.
- 'Cause I saw them and I thought, oh God,
they look like ghost peppers.
- Some interesting shaped
peppers you got there.
- They don't look like the
store, the thin green ones.
They've got like the big plump,
like the shrivel light ones.
- Like Satan's toe.
- Yeah.
- What's the spiciest thing
you've had?
- I'd probably say habanero.
(laughing)
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I mean, other than the
fucking like death sauce
they're like, you know, the-
- Wait, have you ever eaten
like a Carolina Reaper or like-
- Like a ghost pepper.
- No, why would I do that.
- Oh my God, we need to do that.
- No.
- YouTube challenge.
- Why would I do that?
- Because it'll be fun.
- No, no one would want...
For you.
- Let's build up
your tolerance.
- For you guys it would be.
- It's not that bad.
People on YouTube just-
- Trial by fire. (laughs)
- Trial by fire.
Trial by fire. Trial by fire.
- Why did I teach them that phrase?
- People on YouTube when I watched it,
'cause I think I first
saw Rhett and Link do it
back in like 2012, and
they were like. (pants)
It's not that bad.
It is just discomfort.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Why would I willingly
put myself into discomfort?
- Shit makes great content.
- Yeah.
- Fuck you want me there.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- Who doesn't love killing
themselves for content?
- You've eaten like monster
ramen, (indistinct).
That's way worse.
- How did you know?
How did you know I'll do
anything for content? (laughs)
- Yeah, 'cause you're a YouTuber.
- That's how YouTubers' minds work, right?
- You got me there.
- I won't do it.
- Oh, we're gonna film it?
- You're gonna film it?
Okay, okay.
- All right,
next "Trash Taste" special
The winner doesn't have
to eat a Carolina Reaper.
The two losers do.
- Dude, that's gonna be the hardest run
to a W in my existence. (chuckles)
- [Garnt] Yeah..
- And then if it's one of
us, we have to eat three,
and you have to eat one.
- So I'm eating one either way?
- Yeah, of course.
- Let's say you win, me and
Garnt have to eat three.
- Yep.
- But that's not gonna
do anything to you guys.
- No, three will fuck me up.
- Three will. Three will.
- Yeah.
- All right. Fine.
- I'ma be high as fuck.
(laughing)
On those endorphins
- The endorphins like
mess with your head, man.
- It does, it does.
- I remember like the first time,
like the first time I
probably had a ghost pepper
or a Trinidad Tobago or a
Carolina Reaper, the spice high.
I thought I'd heard about it before,
but I didn't realize it was
literally like getting high.
And you feel the after effects
for like hours afterwards,
because you feel this
like warm, tingly glow,
and you just feel like
you did something nice
and you're like, ooh,
what's going on.
- Its when the initial
20 minutes of pain is over,
it's pretty nice.
- Yeah, I mean, I kinda-
- Meilyne looks very
unimpressed and unconvinced.
- I mean-
- It's great.
- It is great.
- I mean, I've had
death sauce (indistinct)
which is technically ghost pepper sauce.
- But like it's-
- It's (indistinct).
- Yeah, but that's the thing, right?
It's like, if we're talking
like just raw peppers,
I've only done having habanero.
- Yeah, I think the spiciest thing,
like singler thing I've ever
had was back in university
where it wasn't even like a ghost pepper,
it was a ghost pepper extract.
- Oh, yeah, the extract.
- Oh, the extract shit.
- Which is like, even more.
It wasn't like a sauce.
- It's concentrated ghost pepper.
- Exactly, it was just
like the pure extract.
And I'd never like, at this point,
I'd obviously like still
grown up on spicy food,
but I'd never had like a ghost
pepper or like a natural,
one of the famous hot peppers
that people do YouTube challenges about.
So I remember we were
drinking and my mate,
he had this ghost pepper extract
that he was like daring people to do.
- He's just carrying it around, was he?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, he's that asshole.
- He was like that guy.
He was the guy you.
You know the guy who would show people,
the two girls one cup kind of videos.
- We all had that one friend.
- Like the pain Olympics.
He was that friend.
- Oh, God.
- So of course, he had this
ghost pepper extract.
- I was that friend.
(laughing)
- (indistinct) only fan I
will go to see was recently,
which I found really funny.
- What was that?
- You (indistinct) go to
was like two weeks ago.
I Didn't know what it was.
And if you don't know what it is,
please don't look it up.
- Don't look it up, please.
- It is someone's cheeks being spread.
That's all you need to know.
- Yeah so he had this
ghost pepper extract,
and of course we were drinking
as you were at university.
- Really? Really?
- And it had gotten to a point
where we were like tipsy enough to start
contemplating doing stupid.
- Of course.
- And, of course,
you know he's-
- Gonna commit credit card fraud.
- Yeah, you know he's
an experienced friend
where he brings it out at
the exactly the right time
of the night where
everyone's intoxicated enough
to think that it's a good idea to-
- Yeah.
- What a horrible mate.
What a fucking...
(Garnt laughs)
What a horrible friend.
Just waiting till everyone
is just semi-stupid
so that he starts feeding them poison.
- Exactly.
So he brings out this
extract and he's like,
"Yo, I dare anyone to
fucking do this," right?
And I see people doing it.
And they're taking like the tiniest,
the tiniest little drop, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's not even a drop,
it's like less than a drop, right.
And I see people fucking dying.
And me being like, yo, yo-
- The giga Chad that I am.
- These weak ass white guys
don't know their fucking spice.
Look at all these guys, right?
And so I say, it gets to my turn,
I'm just like, I'll show
you how man does it.
So like there's-
- Famous last words.
- You've never ever
said that out loud.
(laughing)
That is not a guy phrase.
- No, if there's one
thing I was confident over
it's taking fucking splice level.
- I don't think you'd
ever say, and I quote,
"Let me show you how a man does it."
(laughing)
- So how the extract
works is you have this
tiny little spoon, right?
That you can like put
like one little drip on.
So I fill up the spoon and I just fucking
shove it in my mouth.
- Oh, no.
- What's wrong with you?
Why would you do that?
- I did not know
how spicy it was, right?
And I never knew that
I could literally feel
like I've been shot in
the face until I like...
It was just the biggest instant
regret moment on my life.
Normally you see people taking like,
they take the Caroline
Reaper, they chew on it,
and there's like this delay, right?
No, there was not-
- It's like instant.
- There was not a single delay.
Yeah, my body went into like
fight or flight mode immediately.
Like I was fine.
I took it and then like
five seconds later,
I swear I was in the fucking
fetal position, just like,
ah, ah!
Oh God, it hurts so much.
- I wanna try this now, this sounds fun.
- It' okay.
- What do you what?
What are you on?
- It's interesting, I'd like to try that.
- I will say, I do not recommend it.
As someone who can handle
my spice, I literally-
- It was nice taking, don't worry.
- It was not a pleasant experience.
- I was always that kid who
saw "Jackass" I was like,
I wanna do that.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
Because what happened is
I was out of commission
for the entire night.
- Of course you were.
- Because it was so spicy
that it just induced my gag reflex.
So I was on the toilet,
I was like in the bathroom
for like a good three hours
just like gagging on the toilet.
Couldn't throw up, it was just
like my gag reflex just like,
my body trying to throw up this thing
that was like one little drop.
There was nothing to throw
up, it was like a drop, right?
But it had induced this gag
reflex and I was on the toilet
for about three hours.
And my university mates being
the good mates that they were,
they just kinda went clubbing. (laughs)
- And just left you.
- They just left you while
you were on the toilet.
- What fantastic mates
you have there, Garnt.
- What a fantastic group of mates.
I mean that's why I'm not
friends with them anymore.
(laughs)
- Long story short, I'm not in contact
with any of my uni mates anymore, but-
- I'm not in contact with many either,
but they didn't poison me.
- Yeah, yeah. Exactly.
They were nice to me. (laughs)
- Maybe what if it was all a ruse, Garnt,
where they all agreed to
take small amounts of this
just so that Garnt would
step up to the play
and be like, let me show you
how it's done.
- They're all like,
"We wanna go clubbing but
we dont wanna take Garnt.
How can we knock him out?
- Let's get him out of commission.
I know a way.
I know a way that Garnt
would fall through.
I think that's what they did Garnt, maybe.
- The spice challenge.
I think I've read that
no one has ever died
from spice before or like-
- You could go into shock
though, Garnt, I think so.
- I don't know.
Meilyne, look it up.
Has anyone ever died from spice?
(indistinct)
- Yeah, they can go into shock.
You can't die from the chemical itself,
but you can die from shock.
- You can die from the pain it induces.
- Yeah.
- Which is shock, yeah.
- you can get cardiac arrest.
But its always fun.
- Yeah, basically just don't
do something stupid like-
- You could go into cardiac arrest.
(laughs)
Doctors hate it.
- Just get better arteries.
- Ten ways to stop heart attack.
Don't go under cardiac arrest.
- Just don't take
ghost pepper extract,
or any kind of extracts.
- I wasn't going to, and I
think I'm still not going to.
- Yeah.
I think that's, (indistinct).
(laughing)
- I'm good.
(indistinct)
- You can stop breathing.
- [Meilyne] You can stop breathing.
- Okay.
- Just manually pump
those bitches, just like.
(laughing)
- Garnt, CPR me.
I feel like my lungs stopped.
- It was just like that scene
from fucking "Pulp Fiction,"
where I just passed out
and they have to get
the fucking needle and inject
it straight into my heart.
- Bam!
(laughs)
- Oh, that's so scary.
- Oh my God.
- Oh, God.
- My God.
- So I'm just gonna take
it one step at a time
when it comes to spice.
I'm doing a pretty good job
going up the ladder, I feel.
- Just wondering about CPR, I just, sorry,
'cause it just let's just talk
about (indistinct) my chest,
I feel I'm too British to do CPR.
I feel I'd be like, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Is this too much?
Is this too much pressure?
While I'm trying to save their life.
I'm like, one, oh is that-
- Do you know how to do CPR?
- Yes, so I was a lifeguard
so we had to do it.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, that's right.
Yeah. Yeah.
- Luckily, I always stop
those little before
they stopped breathing.
- Did you ever have to like do it?
- No, God know.
- You'd know which kids were gonna drown
right before they walked in.
(laughing)
100%.
- Why? How do you know.
- I wish I was joking.
- Okay, I might as well just tell stories
about being a lifeguard
'cause it's just so fucking, so many.
So basically whilst I was
working at McDonald's,
I wanted to be a lifeguard
'cause, well, I could swim and-
- It's a good start.
- I was a really strong swimmer
and there was a course that
I did that took about a week.
And it was really weird to have to do,
'cause I had to sacrifice
a week of school vacation.
So I only had one week and I spent it
learning how to be a lifeguard.
I paid like 400 bucks and
then I couldn't get a job
for like a year and a half
'cause they were all like,
"Yeah, you don't have
experience," 'cause I was like 17.
- Oh, that catch-22.
- Yeah, right, they didn't hire me.
But eventually, 'cause
it paid really well.
At the time McDonald's paid
me four pounds, 10 an hour,
which is this much in dollars,
and the lifeguarding paid
nine pounds, 10 an hour.
- Oh wow.
- Which at the time-
- That's a minted job.
- Yeah.
'Cause the thing was you had
to have a week of training.
You'd pay for it all-
- That's a double shift
at McDonald's right there.
- On paper, it looks like an easy ass job,
because all you have to do
is sit there for 30 minutes
and then you get a 20-minute break.
Then you sit there for 30 minutes,
you get a 20-minute break.
And that was it basically.
But when you're new, they put
you on the, at least mine did,
they put me on the shifts
where it was a kid's birthday parties.
'Cause my mom's swam at that pool,
and they never put me on the
shift with the old people,
'cause old people don't drown.
Old people know,
because they swim.
- They know their limits.
- Yeah, 'cause they all
go to the swimming club
all the time and they're not going to,
apart from like freak
accidents, which never happened.
And like people don't
drown in pools in the UK.
The year that I became a lifeguard,
zero people died from pools in the UK.
- Oh, that's good.
- So, it doesn't happen.
Why are you laughing Meilyne?
Until I started the job.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- But like, okay, so have
you ever seen those floats
that take up all the pool?
- Like on the lanes and stuff, or?
- The whole pool.
It's like a big inflatable.
- I've never seen that.
- Yeah, I've seen those.
- You've never seen these.
You have seen these, Meilyne?
You haven't seen these?
Google it.
It's like the picture on screen.
Literally they're these
massive kind of like
total wipe out ass courses
that you can inflate
and they take up the whole pool.
And if you fall off,
you fall in the water.
It's great. Dude, it's bad.
- That sounds fun as fuck.
- When I was a kid, I loved the kid who-
- That sounds like a "Trash Taste" special
waiting to happen, isn't it?
- Imagine like a bouncy house on water.
- That sounds fun as fuck.
What the fuck?
- No dude, it is.
- A bouncy house?
- Imagine a total wipe out
obstacle course on water.
Dude, it's bad.
- Dude, when I was 12, I loved this shit.
- Can we do that?
- Dude, we can go.
- Yeah, I wanna.
- We can probably rent out a pool.
- Hell yeah.
- Yeah.
- Go back to the UK, we're gonna rent one.
- Okay.
- So like you could, basically
for kids' birthday parties,
there'll be like a five or
six-year-old who'd rent it out.
Now, problem is with
kids' birthday parties,
is that not every parent thinks that kids
need to be taught how to swim.
- Right. Right.
- I think 'cause parents forget that kids
need to be taught how to swim.
'Cause you just take it for granted.
So what ends up happening is, obviously,
it's a birthday party.
Everyone invites the whole class.
Now, half the kids in the
class don't know how to swim,
but they still are invited and go anyway.
So, you know, I'd be
sitting that on my thing
and I can tell immediately,
which one of these kids can't swim.
Yeah, they looked like that Joey.
- Oh, that looks fun as fuck.
What the hell?
- Yeah.
- So they'd be like-
- Next special.
- They'd be like
a climbing thing and then
you have to go through pylons
then there's a slide at the end.
Now, you could tell immediately
when you look at these kids,
which couldn't swim.
They just had a look in their eyes
where they were like, fuck!
I've never been in this before.
What do I do?
- And that's a big like thing of water.
- Because they're also, you know,
kids are like that thing
where like most kids
have like a built in danger
system where they're like,
it's like heights, right?
Kids know that they're scared of heights.
Kids know that water is
like weird and scary.
- Yeah.
- And then the kids that
run in it right away,
normally like they can swim.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- But so you'd be doing this
thing and there'd be kids.
And then you'd see this kid,
you can just tell, again.
You can tell he doesn't
look confident, right?
He's techniques poor.
Looking at the water really scared.
- Like toe first into the water, yeah.
- So they climb on this
thing, and bear in mind,
it starts at the shallow end
and it goes to the deep end
where you get off.
And then we're talking like, I don't know,
like two meters deep.
No, no more than that.
It's like five meters deep.
- Five meters?
- Five meters deep
at the pool I worked at.
- That's pretty fucking deep
for a kids pool.
- That's like a diving pool.
- These kids would just walk, right?
And then they'd get to the
end of this obstacle course
and you could see it that
they were like, what do I do?
(laughs)
Everyone else is going down the slide
and they're being egged
on by their friends.
And they just go down the slide
and they would just go down.
- They just sink.
- They just sunk.
They didn't come back up.
(Garnt laughs)
They wouldn't come back up.
- Fucking hell.
- And you would wait
like two seconds just to
like make sure (indistinct).
Just to make sure they don't come back up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then you have two choices.
You can either jump in or you
can get a really long pole
and like poke them with it and hope they.
(laughing)
- Get up.
- Well, normally-
- Let's just hope
they're still alive.
- Hello? Hello, again.
- So basically, if a kid is
splashing around to be like, ah,
you just give him a
pole and he'll grab it.
- Oh, like grab on to it.
- Yes, they'll grab on.
They'll grab onto anything, right?
But if they don't swim and they just sink,
which is like, fuck.
Ah, I gotta fucking go in.
So then I have to go in.
And this should happen
like three or four times
sometimes in like one session.
- Fucking hell.
- Cause these kids
are just terrible.
Sometimes I would go and
jump in, I would get a kid.
I'm like, what are you doing?
Stop, don't go near the deep end.
And then he would go and
he would go near it again.
And I'd blow the whistle
back, what are you doing?
(laughing)
And then I look away for
a second, I look back,
he's at the deep end again,
jumps in, drowns again.
I have to go in and get him.
And tell his parents off, and
his parents have a go at me
and complained to my manager saying that
it's not my place to tell
her what to teach her kids.
And I'm like, it's not my place.
I can just let your kid drown, huh?
See what happens.
- What the fuck?
- She went full Karen mode
on me, trying to get me fired.
'cause I bollocked her in front of her-
- What, because you saved their kid?
- After I saved his kid twice,
I held his hand and I was
like, come, where's your mom?
Show me where your mom is?
And then we went to his mom.
- Where's your mom. (claps)
- I was like,
what are you doing?
- What are you doing?
(laughing)
- I was like why are you
letting this kid into this pool
without any arm bands or anything?
- And she's like, oh-
- Like didn't have
any floaties or anything.
- That's a (indistinct).
Why didn't they have armbands?
- You know what her reason was?
She was like, I don't want him to feel
like he's the weird one,
the one who can't swim.
And I'm like-
- But he's the one who can't swim.
- That's because he can't swim.
He will fucking drown.
Do you understand how this works?
I'm like, did you ever
teach him how to swim?
"No."
Why are you letting him do this?
This is really irresponsible.
And then I just left.
And this was in front of all her friends,
'cause they had like a (indistinct)
And then she complained saying,
I didn't need to do that in
front of all her friends.
It was really inappropriate of me.
I'm like, I'm sorry, but
you saw your kid drown once
and thought, "Oh, I'll
let him keep swimming.
I let him keep going."
That really me off.
I'm still really annoyed about that.
- Yeah, that's just fucking irresponsible.
- That just sounds like bad parenting.
- Yeah, it's terrible parenting.
The people who do stuff
like they would just let
their kids do-
- Unless the parent was
like, "Fuck, I've been trying
to get rid of him."
(laughing)
- The fuck!
- Sabotaged again.
- That insurance plan.
Damn, its really expensive monthly.
- That's a really lay abortion plan.
(laughs)
- [Meilyne] We have it in Japan.
- Do they? Wow!
- Oh my God! Look at that.
- Oh, that looks amazing.
Can you send that
picture when you're done.
- Get ready. Next special.
Were fucking doing it.
- Doesn't this look amazing?
- Fucking hell.
- Dude, it was a really
good job other than that.
It's just like kids that just
like don't know how to swim
and you can tell a moment they can't swim.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, also if you ever tried to,
sometimes if you'd, they taught you
and I never thought I'd have to use this.
They teach you how to
kick someone off you.
if they're like trying to drag you down.
- If you're trying to save someone, right?
- Don't drag me, you're coming with me.
- 'Cause some people when
they think their drowning
they panic, and what they do
is that they push you down.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Cause they think,
I wanna get up.
And, you know, it's not
like a selfish thing
where they're like, "Fuck you."
- I'm dying and you're
dying with me. (laughs)
- Yeah literally, it's like
instincts kick in for them
and they think I'm gonna
push you down to get up
so I can breath.
- What was the technique?
- So what you do is-
- Just like aim for the head.
- No.
( laughing)
(indistinct)
So if they're trying
to like grab on to you
and push you down, you grab
them by the arms and like,
so let's say you're
equal now in the water,
we're both on top of the (indistinct).
You grab them and like you
go down under the water,
kick them up and kick them off you.
- Right, right, right, right.
- You push them away.
And then you usually just grab
them by the face when you-
- What are you doing?
- I'm not kidding.
When you save someone,
you're supposed to grab
them by the chin like this
and like pull them.
- Holy shit!
- Or you can, there's some other ways,
but that's the easiest,
'cause that way you can kinda
just do it at your own pace.
There's other ways that you can grab them,
but that's really awkward.
It depends like how big they are.
And if it's like a child,
like sometimes grabbing them by the face
might be a bit much.
(laughs)
Fuck! Get over here.
- Get over here.
(laughing)
- I just imagine you like
you're wielding children,
grabbing in the face. (groans)
(roars)
- You know the worst thing, when you...
This is the thing that you
don't really think about
is that you don't bring spare uniforms,
'cause that's really your thing.
So if you go in and you save a kid
and it's still your shift,
you just go right back to
the chair and you're soaking.
And you know, some people
they take the time.
Like the first time I did it,
I thought I have to go in right away,
I have to save that life right away.
And I wouldn't take my
shoes off or anything,
but then I realized all the
people who are experienced,
they would just walk down slowly.
They would just take off
their shoes and socks,
'cause they knew they had time,
and they knew like it's a pool.
- They know they're gonna
grab them right away.
So they're like, "I'm not
getting my Nike Air Maxes wet.
What the fuck, bro.
(laughing)
- (indistinct) kid's
drowning and they kinda like
start the timer.
- They sit down like this, right?
They see them like...
'Cause if they're flailing,
you got plenty of time.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So they would just sit.
They'd like walk down
really slowly like this
and they'd be like, "Okay."
(laughing)
Take the watch off like
this, you know, like that.
Then they would go in to get them.
It was really funny.
I just thought it was really bizarre.
I was like, why did you do that?
Isn't that like bad?
They're like, "No, no, no.
They're not gonna drown.
- They're not gonna drown
- I know the average time it
takes for a human to drown.
- Again, the moment I feel worried
is if they don't come back up.
That's when you have to
like immediately go in.
So that was like, that was fine.
And again, this like never happened ever.
This was only with little kids,
'cause little kids are dumb.
I mean, I make out these stories
to be a lot more exciting than they are.
In general, the job was extremely boring.
Like it is one of the hardest jobs to do
just out of sheer insanity.
You sit there for 30 minutes at a time,
just watching people swim.
- Yeah.
- Then you take a 20-minute break
and then you'd go back to it,
and this is like for like six hours.
You're just watching people swim.
And at first it's such
a weird thing to do,
'cause I'm like, yo, what do
people get a problem with me
like staring at them
while they're swimming?
'Cause I'm like, you don't
stare at people (indistinct).
But you're gonna watch the pool, right?
But then you're like, fuck,
is it weird that I'm looking at people,
like there's Parents watching me.
What if they think I'm
looking at their kid too much?
But I'm just making sure that
they're not drowning, okay?
It's not weird, right? (laughs)
- Well, according to (indistinct)-
I wasn't even thinking
about that until he said it.
- This is the thing, these
are the thoughts you have
when you're going insane
sitting there for six hours
thinking like, is it weird?
Is it weird that I'm looking
at everyone for this long?
I'm going insane.
- Sounds like
an existential crisis.
What is my job?
- I legitimately started like
going insane working there.
'Cause I was like, you have to just think
so much.
- How long did you do that?
- God, about just under a year
and then I moved away.
But yeah, I got that job
from doing a different job,
which I talked about at different times.
Just completely different and
it was really funny as well.
But like lifeguarding in general
it was like super boring,
but the pay was really good
'cause you have to get the qualification.
And you have to be taught a lot of stuff.
- Yeah you're there to save lives.
- Yeah, yeah and the course is quite hard,
and you have to redo it every year.
And so I can't be a lifeguard
now 'cause I didn't renew it.
- Oh, right, right.
- But for the one year it was fine.
I mean the pay was insane
for like being 18 and (indistinct).
- And I feel like learning
the basic first aid skills
is really fucking important.
- Yeah, it was really helpful.
- 'Cause I was never taught it at all.
- We don't get taught in the UK.
- Yeah, yeah, we don't get taught,
so I don't know how to do CPR.
They come in once and they're
like, push the chest and blow.
- Oh we-
- I didn't even get that.
I didn't even get that.
- Oh, really?
- We taught it every
year during high school.
- I do not know how to do
the fucking Heimlich maneuver only.
- I need to learn that as well.
- Yeah.
- We just have to learn all the basics-
- I should probably learn it now
because it's gonna be real
awkward if I'm gonna be like,
hold on, let me just bring
up this YouTube tutorial
for a second.
All right, wait, wait,
I got an unskippable ad.
- It's sponsored. It's sponsored.
- I've got an unskippable ad.
Hold on a second. (laughs)
- Wifi. Where's the Wifi?
- A lot of aspects of the
job were fun, but not many.
I had to like clean as well,
like clean all the toilets and showers,
which was like, I mean, I
didn't know I was gonna do that.
- Glad you spent 400
bucks to clean toilets.
(indistinct)
Fucking hell.
- You know, you're there
and when you're wrapping up
and there's no one left in the pool,
you just start cleaning
'cause that's what you're
supposed to do, but yeah.
And then sometimes I had to like,
'cause even though I
wasn't teaching the kids,
but for the kids who
are like one year old,
they're learning how to swim,
there had to be someone in the
water constantly with them.
- Right. Right.
- And those kids just fucking
like don't let go of you.
And it's like, no, get
off me you little shit
It's like WrestleMania with like babies.
It's like, get off me.
You're supposed to learn how to swim.
- But the moment they let
go of the wall they're like.
And they suddenly gained the grip strength
of like a grown man.
It was just, yeah.
I mean, it was all right job, really?
It just paid well, but-
- The kids at the pool were scary.
- Just kids, man.
Kids fucking suck.
And if your kid can't swim,
teach them how to swim.
- I mean like when did you
guys learn how to swim?
- My mom like swims
competitively and still does.
- Wow.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I swear God and Andrea knows.
So she still does like
triathlons and stuff.
- Oh shit.
- And she's one of the fastest
women in her area and she's like nearly 55
or something like that.
- Damn.
- She's a beast.
She's so much more healthy than me.
It's so sad.
When I go back home and she
wants to like go on a bike ride,
I'm like dying and she's
like just breezing it.
- A causal 50K bike ride?
Let's go.
- No, that's what she does.
She's like 50K bike ride?
Nothing.
- Did she watch the cycling special.
I thought I raised you better?
- Yeah, she's like, "Pathetic, Connor."
No, no, no. Really.
If you saw the raw
footage, mom, you can't.
Yeah, so my mom taught me,
I've always known how to swim.
I don't remember not being able to swim.
- I wen to like a swimming school.
- I remember like swimming
was part of my curriculum
in like school.
- Oh, really.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we had like a local
like swimming pool next,
not next to our school,
but like really, really
close to our school.
I remember like Monday mornings
were just dedicated to
learning how to swim.
- That's good.
- Wow!
- I'm not a strong swimmer by any means,
but I still know the basics,
I still know how to swim.
Like to me it's still scary
whenever I go out and I swim
and I can't feel the bottom,
I don't know, there's like,
the fear kicks-
- There's something
so wholesome about hearing that.
- Why?
- I don't know.
It just sounds like a
child problem. (laughs)
When toes can't touch the floor.
- I mean in the swim pool it's fine,
but like out like out in the sea.
I remember the first time-
- No, what's worst is
when I can actually feel
like something underneath-
- You kick something.
- Yeah, you kick something.
That's when I'm scared.
- Yeah, I mean like if, I don't know,
something like in a pool, completely fine.
I don't give a if I can't feel the bottom.
I remember the first time I realized it
when we were on the beach.
It was Brighton Beach's work.
So it wasn't exactly a
fucking thrilling beach.
And I remember like my mates just,
though, we were kinda just
like, oh yeah, let's go swim out
and swim out to where
like the fucking boys are,
and I've never done it before,
but I knew how to swim.
And I remember we got there
and this is the first time in my life
that I had swam that far out.
And this is the first time in my life
where I got to this point
and I started kicking down
and my whole life experience had taught me
no matter how deep it is,
you can still stand up.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- And so it was this
realization where we get there
and we start floating on
the water and I'm just like,
where's the floor?
Where's the ocean floor?
- This is what happens
when you're six foot.
You take floor for granted.
- Yeah, exactly, right?
I never had a swimming pool
where I couldn't like stand up
at least on like my tiptoes.
I sink down a little bit
and then I can still see
the surface of the water,
I'm still on my tip toes.
I can reach the surface quite easily.
So this was the first time
where I'd gone this far out
and I had the realization of, oh, okay.
There is no edges to this pool
that I can quickly grab onto.
I've gotta swim literally
like all the way back
to the fucking beach.
And the beach, like, you
know, that scene in the movies
where the character gets vertigo,
where they look down and
the ground just suddenly
like zooms out, that's exactly how I look.
That's exactly what the beach looked like
when I turned around and it's just like
the beach just went, like that.
And I was just like, oh shit.
- That's why you shouldn't be swimming
if you're getting even like 1% tired,
like you should turn back.
- Yeah, I was already pretty tired.
- You should turn the fuck around.
- That's how people drown.
- That's probably like the closest
I've come to drowning as well.
- People get tired and they swim out
and then they're like,
they're tired by the time they turn around
and they're fucked.
It's so sad.
- And yeah, I remember turning
around and being like, okay,
I've gotta fucking do this
because one of the scariest-
- My life literally depends on it.
And I was like, guys, I
think I gotta turn back.
And I don't think I kind of conveyed
how fucking terrified I was to my mates,
'cause they were like,
"We're just gonna keep going
if that's cool with you."
And I'm like, (pants) okay, okay.
I'm gonna turn back now.
So yeah.
- What a great group of friends-
- Those are bad mates
if they let you do that.
- I mean, I didn't have
a good group of mates
when I was growing up.
- If I heard even like
a breath from my friend
that sounded a little too
heavy and we're swimming,
I'm like, turn the fuck
around and get the fuck back.
- Fucking hell.
- 'Cause when you get further
out, the waves get stronger.
- Yeah, exactly.
And then the currents come in
and that's when it gets
really fucking scary.
I mean, I can't think of
anything more depressing
than just dying on
(indistinct) beach as well.
At least if I'm gonna die on a beach,
let me done a good beach.
- (laughs) Like a nice beach.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Come to Wales, man.
We've got the finest beaches.
We've got the finest beaches, man.
- My fondest memory as
a kid, 'cause Australia,
every fucking house has like a pool in it
'cause otherwise you can't survive
the (indistinct) summer.
- Full luxury.
- You can't survive the summer otherwise.
But my fondest memory,
and I don't know if this
is like a collective memory
for everyone, like every
kid who like swam in a pool,
but did you use to do this thing
where you would go under the water
and then you would
pretend to like walk under
to feel like you were in like on the moon.
- Of course.
- That's the only memory I have
of being in a pool. (laughs)
Even though I went to swimming
school for like seven years
to learn how to like do all
these different swimming things
and like all these fun
activities and whatnot,
the only thing I remember was
like, yeah, I'm on the moon.
(laughing)
- What intelligent
thoughts Joey (indistinct).
I'm on the moon?
- The whole time you're
talking about like the pool
in my head that was just
replaying over and over again.
I'm like, I wanna go swim in a pool again.
It's sad because it's so
hard to like find a place
to swim, yeah.
- There's like no pools here.
Its like they hate
swimming for some reason.
- Unless you fucking pay 150
bucks a month to go to a gym
that also just happens to have a pool.
- I'd paid to go to a gym
with a pool on it, fuck.
I wanna swim.
- I just wanna go in a pool
and swim.
- I haven't seen a pool anywhere.
- Yeah, honestly.
- It's weird to think they
just don't like pools.
- Well, I mean, I don't know
how statistically correct
this is, but there's a lot
of even adults in Japan
that would just never learned to swim.
- I mean if it wasn't
part of my curriculum,
I probably would not
have learned how to swim.
I don't know where I would've
gotten the motivation
to be like, okay, I'm going
to go out and figure out
how I'm going to fucking
play through water.
- Pool's everywhere in the UK.
(indistinct) in the public.
- Yeah. Exactly.
You just pay like two
pounds and you go swimming.
'cause in Australia it's
almost like second nature
to be like, oh, your kid is
like three to five years old.
Well, then we're gonna take
you to swimming school.
No question.
- As someone who's a
lifeguard, was it pretty common
for like you to find
pieces of in your pool?
(laughs)
- Yeah, it happened like
in a year.
- It happens.
- It's like code brown.
So it was like-
- Code brown.
- That's what it was.
You have to empty...
Everyone has to get out and
you have to close the pool.
'Cause you have to re-sanitize it
'cause it's like it's contaminated
'Cause obviously there's
tons piss in there,
but you can't see it.
But the moment you see a giant
mass bar floating in there,
you gotta fish it out and then
you gotta kick everyone out.
Same if like someone throws out,
I think more people throw up than-
- Throwing up in a pool?
Ah, I guess, from drinking
little pool water, right?
- Maybe some kids are
stupid they would like,
some of them would drink the pool water.
Some of them would just eat a lot
and they'd like jump around
and then swim a bunch,
get really exhausted and
then they would throw up.
- How long would it take to
fucking sanitize the pool?
- I don't know. We had
like a Roomba that did it.
There's like a Roomba that
went around the bottom
and there's bunch of-
- Oh yeah, like the little?
Yeah, we used to have these (indistinct).
- And it would go around
and it would clean it,
but the water is like never like emptied.
It's just like recycled, right.
And you gotta do a chlorine
test every like two hours,
make sure the chlorine levels are okay.
But I never did that, I wasn't allowed to.
They were like, "We don't
trust you with chlorine."
- (laughs) We don't
trust you with chemicals.
- "We don't trust yo with
the chlorine, Connor.
Get outta here."
I was never like a manager
there, so I was just like that.
- I remember still having
like fucking vivid memories
when I was like learning how to swim,
just like finding a shit
in like the swimming pool.
- Yeah, it happened like
twice, I think, to me.
- Yeah, 'cause like we would never float.
You would always be at the bottom.
And like as a kid, I was just like you,
'cause I was always been shortsighted.
I was always shortsighted my entire life.
And I didn't know this until
I was like maybe 10 years old
that I was shortsighted. (laughs)
Oh my God.
Actually, I remember. (laughs)
I remember as a kid, I would
be sitting really close
to the TV because like when
I'm playing games all day.
My mom was just like, "Stop
sitting so close to the TV."
And I was like, but I can't see it.
And my mom's just like, "Look harder."
(laughing)
You're not looking hard enough.
- Get better eyes.
- Oh my, Garnt.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
And it was only when we realized
that when I (indistinct).
- The audience will fight.
- I was just born with bad
eyesight unfortunately.
So as a kid, I didn't
have glasses at the time,
so I would be swimming in the pool
and I would see this like little,
I remember seeing this like
little black fucking thing,
like in the corner of this pool, right?
- What did you do?
- And it was fucking
blurry as fuck, right?
I'm just like, what the is
this black thing in the corner.
I've never seen in the corner pool.
And so like out of, you know,
they say curiosity killed the cat.
So me being the curious little, you know,
`fucking six-year-old I was or whatever,
I swim closer and closer
to it, right? (laughs)
- And looking back, I can
hear the fucking "Jaws" music
just playing in the background.
I'm like, ta-na, ta-na.
I start swimming closer and closer it
and it starts like slowly, slowly-
- Enhancing.
- Slowly, slowly coming into focus, right?
And it starts like, okay, so
it becomes this blurry mess
and it becomes this cylinder shaped thing.
And I'm just like, what the
fuck is a cylinder shaped thing
doing in the swimming pool, right?
And so I get closer and I get closer,
and then I'm literally like,
so the the shit's there, right?
And so I literally was just like.
(laughs)
(claps)
'Cause like when it felt like
it fully came into focus,
obviously when I'm this close
I can see the entire fucking
detail in everything.
- You're like two inches
away from pieces of shit.
- Yeah, you can see the fucking texture
of the shit right now.
Like that's how detailed
it was in my mind.
I let out the biggest underwater scream
I had of my fucking life.
(laughing)
It was literally like
a fucking horror movie
when I'm just like, (screams).
- You know what the... (laughs)
That's such a good story.
- Oh my God.
- That's a great story.
- The weirdest time there
was a shit in the pool,
and this happened to me
twice while I was there.
And I was just completely confused
at how there was a shit in the pool.
And I still to this day cannot
figure out what happened.
So I'd love some scientists
in the chat to explain
what the fuck happened.
- Yeah.
- So they would do this thing
at my pool where they would have like,
how to learn how to kayak.
So they would let like six people-
- Like in the pool.
- Yeah, they would put
six kayaks in the pool
and just let people kayak around it.
And I don't know how this happened,
but after the kayakas left,
there was a shit in the pool.
Now, they're in kayaks.
How did it get in the pool?
- Did some of them just window,
like put that butt out just for a second,
just like squeeze it out.
How does that happen?
How is there shit in
the pool after kayaks?
Does anyone have an idea
of how this happened?
We were all completely confused
and luckily it was the end of the day,
but we were just like, how
is there shit in the pool?
- You're looking back at like
the security footage camera.
It's like, "We gotta find the exact moment
when the poop came out.
- We wish. We wish.
- We wish we had security
footage to fucking analyze
if someone had done a cheeky shit.
Did they bring it and drop it in?
Like, did they do it in the kayak
and then just fucking scooch it in?
Like what happened?
To this day, I wake up in a cold sweat
wondering how did that shit get in there
- Wait, were they like
adults in the kayak?
- No, it was just like
15, 14, 13-year-olds.
- What 15, 14-year-old is like,
"I'ma in this pool." (laughs)
- Kids are fucking weird, man.
- Kids are weird.
- But you think like
after like the age of 12,
you think like-
- Nah, nah, dude.
- There is like a mental stop in my brain
to be like, no, pooping
in the pool is bad.
(indistinct)
- Some kids so dirty, though.
They don't give a shit.
- (scoffs) Gross.
- I mean, even just
pissing in the pool, right?
- I've done it.
- Everyone's done it.
- It's something we don't-
- I'm not gonna pretend like I
don't piss in the pool, okay?
- It's something that
we don't like to admit,
but of course everyone's done it.
- Everyone does it.
- Right, Meilyne?
- Never.
- Right, Meilyne? (laughs)
- Sounds like smelling your own fart.
Everyone does it.
- Sometimes, you just get in
the pool and you realize,
fuck, I need to piss.
- Yeah
- I just got in.
- Yeah, I don't wanna get out.
- I'm not getting out, I'm gonna piss.
Everyone else is doing it.
We're all just drinking
each other's piss anyway.
This pool is massive, no one will know.
- It's got chlorine in it for a reason.
- Waving around a bit.
- Stop (indistinct)
whatever it is.
- What?
- It's a fucking pool, Meilyne.
- It's a public pool, Meilyne.
- Public pool is basically piss.
Why do you think they put fluoride in it?
- Michael Phelps says
he pisses in the pool?
If Michael Phelps can piss in the pool,
I can piss in the pool.
- Yeah, it propels him, right?
It's like an extra jet engine.
- He is the gold standard of swimmers.
If he can piss in the pool,
as far as I'm concerned,
I can piss in the pool.
- That's like a just propel,
It's just like through here.
- I'm not shitting in the pool.
- No.
- I'm not doing it, come on.
- Big difference between
pissing and shitting.
- One of them evacuates the pool,
the other one is everything
everyone else is doing.
Its not a problem, whatever.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I will not have to
justify pissing in, okay.
I don't just get in every pool
and I'm like, (indistinct).
It's pissing time.
- I'm about to pee.
- All I'm saying is if you're
in a wet suit on or something,
it's like, you know what?
I'm gonna make myself warm.
- You know who else pisses
in the pool, though?
Our Patreons.
- Yeah, they do.
- Yes.
(laughs)
- All of these people
definitely pee in the pool.
- They definitely piss in the pool.
Look at all these lovely
people right here.
- Who piss in the pool.
- Look at all these lovely
pool pissers, right? (laughs)
- We've gone from fucking from spicy food
to fucking pissing in the
pool while we do an episode
of "Trash Taste"
- Sounds like a "Trash Taste
episode to me,
But hey, if you'd like
to join the Patreon,
then make sure to go to
the patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, yeah.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your means on the subreddit,
and if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
- Yeah, and I think that's
everything for today,
right, lads?
We've had a pretty colorful episode today.
- I don't even remember what
we fucking talked about.
- [Garnt] I don't remember
what we talked about.
- I probably always mentioned shit.
What the fuck's wrong with us.
- I'm glad we ended it on
what we usually ended on,
which is Poopoo Peepee stories.
- Poopoo Peepee.
Poopoo Peepee stories.
- Exactly.
- If you didn't know, we
have "Trash Taste After Dark"
where we occasionally
stream live on Twitch
and the vlogs get uploaded
to that YouTube channel.
- Yeah, so if you'd like
to check out our Twitch
and also our "After Dark" channel,
check out the description below.
- Thank you so much for watching gamers.
See you soon.
- Yeah, and we will
see you guys next time.
Bye.
- Bye.
(gentle upbeat music)